I am once again eating my dinner.
Hello everybody, I'm back.
Oh, hi everybody.
Oh, hi, oh, oh,
oh, oh.
We may be made in this, but we're made full.
Thank you guys.
Thank you.
Thank you, thank you, thank you, thank you.
What am I eating today?
I'm eating chicken and rice once again.
And once again, eating chicken and rice.
Hold on.
I meant I found four kittens in a storm drain near my house.
What do they...
What do...
Oh, what do?
They look healthy and are so, so, so cute.
Keep.
Four kittens, that's a lot, though.
That's a lot.
Chicken is appropriate considering the game.
So true, we went to the chicken kitchen, didn't we?
Chicken kitchen, chicken, chicken, chicken, chicken,
chicken.
No.
Sounds healthy.
Unless it's karage.
It's not karage.
I'm kind of healthy sometimes.
I'm kind of healthy.
Howdy, howdy.
Hope you're well.
Detect the phantoms.
Wait, getting news.
This may not be the point.
Thanks to the Super Chat!
I wonder what this buy and send button does.
You might want to check your bank account.
I think that'll answer it.
I think.
Maybe.
Mmm, karage.
Now I'm thinking about karage.
Bye, chicken.
Mmm.
Yummy!
Welcome back to Ghost Trick.
I kind of want to just get into it today, if that's okay.
I kind of want to just dive right on in so we can start
doing some ghost tricks and tips and tricks.
What was I going to say though?
Oh, I was going to do a recap.
Thank you, thank you.
Thank you!
Uh...
Did you hear that?
Maid, Momo and Midori are going to be playable.
What?!
They're gonna be playable!
Have fun ghost drinking!
I did not hear that.
Maid Momo and Midori!
I will get them both.
Goodbye.
Goodbye, jemmies.
Yay!
Eat the nummy mouth food with your mouth using mouth food
eating techniques that have been passed down through the
generations like onto mouth food eating techniques that get
passed down yeah
that was certainly a sentence that's just yoko he's always
like that
true yeah i can't i mean eating has been passed down right
also oh my gosh garlam all thank you for Before the stream
started, thank you so much!
Recap!
Sorry, I have to, like, lean over to get my food.
Because of the way my desk is.
Where did we...
I know where we left off on.
But I'm trying to think of what...
Okay, so...
Oh, we started with the execution.
And we had to turn the power off.
And we had to get our...
Get the Chadman...
in a very stealthy sequence.
Omji, the bank just charged me.
Lamau, Lamau, Lamau, get charged, get charged, get charged.
Chad Jowd.
Yes, Detective Jowd.
And we watched a guy gulp down a bunch of pills.
Yes, that happened too.
Yes, yes, yes.
So we got him through the jail.
He jailbreak, baby.
But then he got caught.
It was all for nothing.
He got caught by Elvis Detective.
Did Lynn die again?
I don't think she did.
I just finished catching up to your previous Ghost Trick
streams.
I'm right on time.
Let's go!
Thank you so much for watching them.
I really appreciate it.
Thank you.
Silly boy, welcome to membership.
And so then, after that, happened And after we got him out,
Lynn went to the commissioner guy to say, stop his
execution.
But we realized the reason he's going through with the
execution, maybe Cortex with a five-gifted thingies of it,
the reason he's going through with the execution is because
his daughter has been kidnapped by the hot blue lady.
Yippee!
Yeah!
Blue lady!
so um we ended off on um but actually the daughter wasn't
kidnapped if she was just a hot lady um as a ghost what's it
feel like when you encounter offuda or she day
as a ghost i feel nothing every day i feel nothing
what was i gonna say oh
and oh yeah we're now checking out the hot blue lady so i'm
excited for this part so we're challenges oh wait just
kidding oh i'm sorry i was under extras we're under continue
how's the audio i think the main menu is a little quiet but
um yes see the auto save we're at 12 10 a.m
Oh yeah, we did save the Commissioner's life by giving him
his meds.
He went...
He...
He was used to that.
He was...
Yeah.
Um, but yeah, let's go back into the auto save.
Let's just get right into it, baby.
I wonder if I should turn DVR off for this.
So people coming in can just kind of watch.
10 a.m.
The justice minister's daughter has been abducted.
The kidnappers demand the execution of the death row
prisoner Zhao to be carried out tonight.
Yes, this is a good recap.
She's so high.
Oh, oh, ma'am.
Even your silhouette.
Look at the way she just just power sits.
I've never seen a power sit before like that.
Lynn says the execution is a mistake and I believe her.
So I'm paying the kidnappers hideout a visit to see what I
can find out about the abduction yeah that's a practice sit
I want to be that chair I want to be that chair wanna be
that chair wanna be that chair wanna be that chair Mike
Tyson thanks for the vibe gifted what took you so long who's
here Oh, my goodness.
Your instinct was right, Beauty, my dear.
No, not this guy.
They had that restaurant surrounded.
It took me forever to shake them.
And now my poor bike is ready for the scrap heap.
Not Shaggy.
Forgot about the voice.
It fits him, though, doesn't it?
Ugh.
Whoa!
Next time, maybe you should st- Oh no, I can't be hot.
I can't do it.
Next time, maybe you should make it a tricycle so you don't
hurt yourself.
Ouch, that hurts, beauty.
But that's okay.
That's what I love about you.
I can't unhear Shaggy.
I'm doing the voice I'm doing the voice And I can't unhear
Shaggy No Bum Oh
Happy birthday Be a little more gentle With our valuable
hostage please Oh wait is she in the box Zoink scoop Yes yes
Always keep a smile on a lady's face Right mighty There.
See that beauty?
Uh, maybe that's better.
There's a smile blooming on your face too, my dear.
I bought, played, and finished this after your second
stream.
All the characters were voiced in my head as you had voiced
them.
Thanks, I think.
You are truly minto.
Minto-minded.
Minto-minded, minto-minded.
Thank you so much.
Yes, a rye smile.
I'm going out for a breath of fresh air.
You're on guard duty.
All right.
I'll dream of you until you return.
Why don't you open the trunk for our guest?
I will, beauty.
I was just taking a little breather.
So when I asked for sultry Minto a while back, this was it.
Oh!
Also, I am gonna turn up the sounds just a little bit.
Maybe like that.
Sorry, I just don't want it being... I know I do this every
time.
Jaho!
Thanks for the gifting!
Alright, little lady.
Let me open that trunk for you.
Oh.
Okay.
Oh, is he actually going to fall asleep?
Beauty.
Oh, wait.
There was a birthday party here.
Look, because there's, like, streamers, and then there's a
birthday cake.
Looks like the Justice Minister's daughter really has been
kidnapped.
Something else is bothering me, too.
Wait, if we go back to their house, though, I don't think
I've ever been to this room before.
But something about it is giving me a strange sense of deja
vu.
this before yes this is just like the room in the that that
Lynn got killed in I'll let you guess which one trick time
trick time trick time taking something oh okay I want to
bring something up that someone uh one big streamer on am I
too big here I'll make myself small sorry am I too big um so
last time I played I got I saw like a comment from someone
that said that they were kind of sad that I was skipping
some of the funniest dialogue because because I was trying
not to get hints for the puzzles and while I understand that
you know sometimes I there might be stuff that I miss in
general you know I'll be I'll do better about you know what
i won't care so much about the hint stuff so so much this
time um if anything not big enough thank you for the first
ever super time thank you thanks to vegetable ghosts but um
so but also i i you know and sometimes in games like this
there might be stuff that i miss so um that's just kind of
the nature of these types of games maybe dialogue so um some
of the funny dialogue is in the word bubbles yeah so um i'll
do my best to um to to hit them but sometimes i might forget
so yeah sorry if i do okay that's all i wanted to talk about
since i got reminded because of the bubble taking something
precious to manipulate others So that's what kidnapping is.
I guess.
But doesn't the kid need to be involved?
The dirty tricks those without...
Wait.
The dirty tricks those without the powers of the dead.
Oh.
Oh!
The dirty tricks those without the powers of the dead come
up with.
My goodness.
I cannot comprehend this.
Deposit in Mint Bank TM.
Thank you.
DING!
Deposited.
However, if I take that precious thing back...
Marissa, oh my god.
Sissel stole the precious thing.
Kirai.
If I take that precious thing back, their power vanishes,
doesn't it?
So true.
Look at this.
Look at this bozo sleeping on the job.
Now then.
Time to see Jahat.
how the justice minister's little girl is doing before this
guy wakes up from his dream of beauty oh he's snoring i'm
going ghost swing decoration decoration what's this down
here let's open the door i think that'll get us furthest oh
uh open the door i get
Wait, I pressed X.
Oh, okay.
I can't go trick.
Okay, never mind.
What are you...
What are you, what are you, yoni?
So...
Swing!
Oh.
It doesn't do so much.
Okay.
Swing!
Why does it go so far to the left but not to the right?
Okay, there was one other thing we can do, which is this.
Burn dry.
Oh!
It's on fire!
Oh my god!
Oh, we just... Oh, we just caused a fire.
Wait.
Oh!
But that's gonna drop then.
I knew it!
Here I thought we were gonna be setting the place on fire.
But, uh...
Okay, now we swing here.
Let's spin faster.
Spin, spin, spin, spin, spin.
Oh, interesting.
Oh, my bad.
Hold on.
Let's see.
What did that say?
The ball.
A ball.
All that rolls off a table.
I've already seen something like this once already tonight.
It's true.
I wonder if this ball does anything.
Now we're here, here, lower the shade, move the sconce,
suspend the shelf, I mean, mantle the clock.
Let's move down.
Lower the shade.
Oh.
I'm under his...
Oh, darn.
I can't reach my destination from here.
Oh.
Okay.
Thank you.
What if we rock and the clock falls?
No.
The shelf is suspended by very thin cords.
They look like they're about...
to break.
I bet it'd be quite a spectacle if that if something can
break it oh wait if something can break it kind of makes me
want to break it.
Oh my gosh Cicil why are you such a why are you such a
troublemaker huh?
That just huh?
This is one of those things you light with fire isn't it?
Do we need to really set this place on fire?
As long as there's light in the room Is something like this
really necessary?
But if something can be lit, it kind of makes you want to
light it.
I need another core to reach the trunk and open it.
I wonder if I can create a new core.
So we need to burn this.
We need to set things on fire, baby.
He is truly a menace.
Doll.
Let's go back to where we were.
before.
Oh, I'm already feeling myself getting so hungry.
Wait.
Oh, wait.
Yeah, we can uh...
We can...
We can go back this way.
Like so.
Okay.
Easy peasy.
Hmm.
Now, if I open the door...
Oh!
I was gonna possess the ball.
Hmm.
Food check.
I have my food.
It's just hard to eat when I'm reading so much.
much you know sorry guys uh before before stream i was uh
recording with um with matara for the podcast um um we
started kind of late because we both got back from doctor's
appointments late
okay can i set anything else on fire
Fire.
Hmm.
What else can we set on fire?
Oh, nice, nice, nice.
Oh, we can...
Fire!
Burn, baby.
Burn.
My heart.
Heartburn?
If you have a heartburn, Heartburn, are you okay?
I don't want to do this out of order and have to restart, so
let's see.
The present?
Hmm.
Set our hearts ablaze.
You want me to set you on fire?
Joshua, thank you!
Good evening, A few more dollars for the Minto Bank.
Have you heard...
Hearing you sing Final Fantasy songs, warms my JRPG loving
heart.
Do you have a favorite Final Fantasy game?
I'll be honest, I haven't played so many Final Fantasy
games.
So I probably like my first one, which was...
Well, actually I played Final Fantasy XII first.
But I really like Final Fantasy X and XII.
Hmm.
Let's see what happens if we spin this.
It's going to go up.
And then it goes back down.
Okay, but I can't do anything while it's doing that.
Okay.
Cool.
Maybe.
Maybe we have this firecracker.
Okay, you know what?
Let's just go.
Party popper.
Fire!
I was gonna say maybe if I was gonna say maybe would get
something stuck either on the spinner or on the fan Nice
Okay 6 9 and 12 are my favorites Oh and then I've also I've
played a little bit of 7 But I know I've watched
Playthroughs of 7 so Just my imagination That's all he has
to say.
If he was any more laid back, he'd fall right off that
crate.
But look at that streamer going, go, go spinning round and
round.
Now how can I make use of that?
Yes, yes, yes.
Where am I?
Oh, I'm on the party popper.
Maybe we get it tied up here.
Get tied up!
it reach?
Not enough for the fire.
I think I'm just gonna have to set the place on fire.
Fire!
Oh!
That leads, just my imagination.
That leads straight up to the fire.
Fire, fire.
Light the fire.
What an amazingly simple fellow.
This room, on the other hand, is starting to look amazingly
festive.
The question is, how can I use it to my advantage?
Okay.
If I bring this up now, what does it do?
It's all tied up.
Interesting, okay.
I'm still confused what to do with the spinning guy, though.
I'm actually kind of stumped.
Hmm.
Yeah, there's a candle on the doll too.
Yes, I have noticed that.
I have noted that, yes.
I think does the string...
Hold on, let's see.
Does it reach...
No, it doesn't...
I was like, maybe if that catches on fire and then spins
over to her...
Hmm.
We've done...
Let's raise it...
The fire again, maybe.
Shoo!
Ghost!
And back this way.
Oh, dang.
And this way.
And this way, this way, this way, this way.
Burn brighter.
Not.
Doesn't reach.
When the flame gets really big like this, for some reason I
get the urge to burn something.
Unfortunately, everything is just out of the flame's reach.
Yeah.
There's nothing else I can interact with except the door.
Oh, come on.
Oh, maybe it's been faster.
That's right.
Ah!
Oh!
Okay.
That's right.
Ah!
Okay, there we go.
There we go.
Burn!
Burn, burn, burn, burn, burn, burn, burn!
Oh my god.
Oh my god, it's on fire.
Oh, I figured it out.
Good luck.
I figured it out too.
Wait.
Okay, so that's on fire now.
And now we need to raise this to be on fire as well.
I figured it out too.
Spin!
What about the ball, though?
Nice!
Oh!
Just your imagination.
Yep.
Ten-sai.
Thank you, thank you.
And we're in, baby.
That's the daughter!
Wait, she's just chilling.
What in the...
What's going on here?
Whose footprints are these?
This little lady is.
Her, I thought it was the girl in the bed.
Is this little lady really a daughter of the justice
minister?
Oh, just my imagination.
It was not...
Oh.
Uh.
They caught the wrong girl.
What's with the fun book and juice?
Oh.
Like I said, always keep a smile on a lady's face.
I wanted to treat our guest well.
How about treating me well?
Ooh!
Oh my gosh, Shaggy.
Are you telling you're not treating my girl well?
Should have been me.
I'll treat you well.
I'll treat you well, Madam Blue.
Mm-hmm.
I volunteer.
Mmm.
I'd like some bread and milk, please.
Not your sir.
Oh,
no, am I shaggy?
Why did I know what he was going to say?
Oh, no.
I don't know.
You're a maid, that's why?
Yes, yes, yes, yes.
That's all, that's all, that's all.
It's only because I'm a maid, everybody.
It's only because I'm a maid.
made everybody oh no at your service my dear me back in a
flash you better skedaddle out of there I better see you I
better see dust coming off your feet from running so fast
hey mister I think she also wants bread and milk yes cute
little lady more juice perhaps all you have to do is Have I
been... kidnapped?
Oh...
No cry, little dear.
There's nothing to be afraid of.
The surroundings are miserable and filthy, I know, but we
just ask for a little patience.
Don't say those awful things about this house.
Hmm...
This house is...
Where I used to live.
So what does...
What does the guy from the...
How does the guy...
From the junkyard...
Know...
What her room looks like?
Zoinks.
What?
Nani?
I apologize, little lady.
I'm the one who's miserable and filthy.
Forgive me.
Wait, so I think my theory last time was that was that Lynn
killed the mom but now I'm thinking it was accidentally her.
What's her name?
Now I'm thinking is that maybe it's her But Lynn still knows
the truth about Detective Jowd.
Camilla, Camilla, yeah, yeah, yeah, Camilla, Camilla.
DL6 Incident.
Ah, that would be on, that would be, that would be on brand
for this, for this creator.
What's the meaning of this beauty?
Why here at this little, at this girl's old house?
Don't ask me.
It was the other party in our deal who chose this location.
Oh, oh, I see.
It's been empty for five years, and apparently nobody ever
comes here.
But never mind that.
What about my bread and milk?
Oh, oh, of course.
Skedaddle now, Shaggy.
Now you be a good girl while I'm gone.
Oh my god, look at him tiptoe.
Hurry up!
Go get the bread and milk!
Let the ladies speak.
You just read your book and drink your juice.
You'll never know the truth.
There's not a parrot in sight.
I want to go home.
Not quite yet.
Hmm.
This dilapidated place was Camilla's old house?
What's going on here?
Trick time.
Alright, Camilla.
Camilla...
Wait, what?
What in the world?
Why does the little lady have a core of the dead?
I was gonna say, she never died before.
When I helped her out at Lynn's apartment...
Wait, no, she did die technically, though, right?
Because...
Um...
Wait, actually, I'm not sure.
Wait.
No.
Because he killed the dog and then her.
But we never talked to her.
it was her dog oh you're right
maybe I just assumed that she was going to die but it was
actually her going to get kidnapped
when I helped her out Lynn's apartment she didn't have one
so that must mean
she must have died sometime after that Once again, the
incident.
Wait, what incident?
And it also means somebody else must have saved her.
Wait, what?
I'd better ask her what happened.
Unless something that we fixed saved her, right?
That could happen.
What's the book she's reading?
A book.
I wonder what the little lady is reading tonight.
story maybe?
Although she's already getting quite a bit of excitement for
one day.
Look at her sipping, she's so cute.
Somewhere along the way, Camilla must have died.
What could have happened to her?
I better ask her.
Could it be?
There's somebody else with the powers of the dead besides
me!
Okay, let's get inside her brain.
Who's there?
Oh, wait a minute.
Is that Wait, Missile!
Missile!
I'm sorry, I'm not Missile.
My name's Cecil.
Did Missile save her?
No way.
Cecil?
My name is Camilla.
Yeah, where is Missile actually?
Camilla.
So it is her.
I knew it.
What happened to me?
What is this place?
I can hardly tell the poor little thing.
Oh, I can hardly tell the poor little thing.
This is the land of the dead.
The land of the dead?
Does that mean...
Oh, she could hear her thoughts.
Does that mean I'm dead?
Darn!
I forgot there are no secrets in the ghost world!
You can relax.
You're not dead.
But this isn't the first time you've been here, apparently.
Really?
I don't remember.
There are no thoughts here.
Wait a minute.
Maybe I do remember.
Sort of.
Wha!
May
I have a birthday song?
My wish this year is to go to Mint's Meet and Greet.
Thank you!
Of course I can sing you.
Hold on.
For some reason, it's so loud for me, but it's not so loud
for you.
I will sing you happy birthday.
Hold on, let me...
Let me hold on first.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday to you Happy birthday dear
Happy birthday to you I hope your birthday wish comes true
Also I saw someone say that the game is loud?
It is?
How about here?
Maybe I do remember, sort of.
It's fine?
You do?
It looks like she doesn't remember being saved very well.
Oh, sound good before?
Like there?
Hmm, so there's some other dead person out there with
special powers, eh?
Anyway, I don't want to press her if she doesn't remember
dying.
about something else sure go ahead sissy sissy I am
kidnapping Lynn asked me to do something for her tonight I
know about that part she asked you to go to the chicken
kitchen on dead-end drive right sissy yeah but I never got
there now I wish I could say I'm sorry to her I never should
have gone through that park what Temsik Park It's a shortcut
to dead end drive Oh my gosh Should she like get hit by the
truck Did she get Yasekai'd?
Is that where the kidnappers grabbed you?
Lynn always says Always said I don't like that park Scary
things happen there That's where She also Got held hostage
right?
Yeah that's where we Um That's where she got held hostage.
HMS, welcome to membership.
Thank you so much.
Thank you, thank you.
Temsik Park, eh?
What am I going to do?
Lynn's going to be so mad.
Aw.
She's not going to be mad that you got kidnapped.
Well, she's going to be mad that you got kidnapped.
Yeah, she's going to be mad.
She is?
How come?
Uh-uh.
Uh-oh.
Because I left it there.
It's probably the music box.
Vanilla look, the membership.
Mm-hmm.
The music box in the park.
This is the music box that, um...
That, uh...
Detective Jowd said that we needed to look into.
That's right, the music box!
Oh, let's ask her.
That music box was hidden in the apartment.
I finally found it with a little bit of luck and courage.
and me.
Actually, just me.
Guess where it was?
I don't know.
Where?
I'll pretend I don't...
She can still hear our thoughts.
I'll pretend I don't know.
You know.
Tala!
Welcome to membership.
You don't have to humor me.
Oops.
So what happened to the music box?
I hid it in the bushes at the park just before it happened.
Just before...
Oh, just before you were kidnapped, huh?
I didn't want the bad man to take it, so I hid it.
I bet it's still there in the park.
You did well.
So the music box is in the park.
I'd better let Lynn know.
Alright, let's ask about Camilla.
This is your old house?
Yep, this is where we lived until five years ago.
But now I live with Lynn and Missal.
Lynn is like a big sister to you, isn't she?
Yep, she's a detective, you know.
She's a hero.
She is, huh?
Why are you so surprised by that?
By the way, about your father.
Is he the justice minister?
My father is... gone.
Gone.
Maybe he passed away?
No, that's not it.
My dad...
His detective Zhao.
He's going to die!
And it's all because of me!
What do you mean because of me?
Why would you say that?
Oh my god, was I right?
It's called an ex- Uh-oh.
Uh-oh.
It's called an execution.
My dad is a detective.
No way!
Don't tell me your father is Detective Jowd!
That's right.
I so called it.
What in the world?
5 years ago something really bad happened Like a scary dream
But it wasn't a dream 5 years ago That murder case
Was the guy in the She didn't kill her mom either Was the
guy In the park In the junkyard Was he recreating how How
The mom died?
You know?
Oh, maybe.
Or something...
Um...
What are you cooking?
Five years ago, that murder case.
Incident five years ago.
that was my mom's birthday that day my mom and dad were
working and I was home by myself and then I had an idea I
was going to surprise my mom she set up a contraption and
she thinks she killed her mom I set up okay what the hell I
promise I have not played this game before I promise what is
going on literally the next line am i i'm so psychic today
wow pre-watched are you reading a synopsis man no i promise
i promise i set up that contraption oh my god i'm home
camilla why is it dark oh my god
And then it set on fire and everything died.
Dun, dun, dun, dun, dun.
Oh my god.
Wait.
Why?
What was the point of all the rest of it?
Why did you set this up?
What did you think was going to happen?
What was that noise?
I still can't believe it happened.
It wasn't supposed to work like that!
So someone messed with it.
Someone tampered with her contraption.
Hmm, I know that contraption.
Yes, it's exactly what I said, and I know how it was
supposed to work.
Wait, how is it supposed to work?
Wait, I know how it was supposed to work?
It was supposed to...
The poppers.
Yeah, it was supposed to do the poppers.
That's right.
Party poppers and a cake and a birthday message.
Yes, yes, now I remember.
Now I remember.
Camilla lost her mom to a TikTok challenge.
Don't say it like that.
Mint hasn't played the game before.
That means she made it.
I haven't seen the creator of Ghost Trick and Mint in the
same room before.
Yes, we redirected the Cupid.
That's right.
But also, why was the gun loaded?
My dad told me not to tell anybody.
Just leave it to me, he said.
Aww, poor girl.
My dad wanted to be executed.
He asked them for it.
Okay, name welcome to membership.
But I wanted to tell everybody it was my fault.
My dad said, what I saw was a bad dream.
He told me to forget it.
So unbelievably tragic.
Miracle.
Who doesn't have a loaded gun on their wall?
So true.
I can't believe it.
This little lady is Detective Jowd's daughter.
Girl, your contraption is absolutely killing it.
I can't tell her.
I just can't tell her.
I can't tell her why she was kidnapped.
ZK, thanks for the 10 gifts.
Thank you.
Why was I kidnapped?
oops there are no secrets in the ghost world maybe we'd
better stop talking it's too dangerous sissy you're not
going to talk to me anymore I think we better get get you
out of here first we could talk more after that okay but
oops I love how he just goes oops whoopsie poopsie I'm going
to rescue you now you just hold on a little longer all right
okay but we'll talk later right don't forget you promise
sissy
yuppie different places have different traditions birthday
punches birthday death contraptions they're all equally
valid only only the strong survived the birthday contraption
what took you so Wait, sorry, what took you so long?
I traveled in the entire town in search of the finest bread
and milk for you, my dear.
But it's late, and all the shops are closed.
We're leaving this place right now.
I don't know, I can't get her voice right anymore.
What?
But he's not here yet.
If we couldn't meet at the restaurant, weren't we supposed
to meet here?
Yes, and he is the one who chose this location.
I don't like this one bit.
I can never unhear Shaggy.
I think I'm leaning more into the Shaggy since I can't stop
it.
It's just happening.
Let Shaggy take over, okay?
Let, let, kind of sounds like Shaggy from Skiba.
Just let the Shaggy take over, okay?
We have to run around doing all this extra work for the sake
of his deal.
Be quiet.
It can't be held.
This place is too dangerous.
I told you, my sixth sense is very strong.
Oh, she senses me.
As you wish me, UD.
I feel it.
I sense something here in this room.
It's me.
Is somebody there?
Can you hear me?
She's talking to me!
She's talking to me, you guys.
She's talking to me, straight to me, straight to me.
I can sense your presence, you know.
The next time I sense you, this child will...
This child will die.
Remember that.
Oh my god.
Okay.
I'm just obsessed with you.
All right.
We're leaving.
Pardon me, little lady.
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
Oh, recently discovered VTubers and I love your streams.
Really?
Thank you so much.
Thanks, do guy.
Thanks for the super chat.
Like soinks mint.
We gotta get out of here.
Okay.
All of a sudden I'm left behind alone.
Alone in the room that stole that little lady's smile away
five years ago.
The little lady is gone now, leaving me with only a few new
facts.
A few very heavy, very sad facts.
Does Lynn know about all this?
Bro, raggy.
One other thing stands out in my mind.
I can sense your presence.
The sum of that kidnapper's final words.
Do those two know?
Do the kidnappers know about the powers of the dead?
Would you spare the girl for a scooby snack?
Bada, bada, bada, bada, bada.
Yay!
Cleared the 1225 challenge.
It's crazy that all of this happens in just like 15 minutes.
Oh my gosh, Camilla is so cute!
Continue playing.
Of course.
I don't know what chapter we're on now.
Oh!
Chapter 12.
Yeah.
40 minutes late.
Now I feel so lost.
I can catch you up.
Here.
Read this.
Hold on.
I'm going to eat.
You read it.
Someone read it out loud.
Beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep.
Boop, boop.
Welcome to why you're stuck here.
All your earthly possessions now belong to Vita Wars.
You've missed your chance to run.
Thanks for your super tie.
I'm glad, am I glad she's trapped in there?
And that we're trapped out there?
And that she's the daughter?
And that we're in there?
I just remembered we're out here.
Where's Miss Camilla?
Thank you.
What do you call a ghost ad?
A transparent.
Ah, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha.
Get it?
Because he's transparent.
He's a ghost.
Looks like the kidnappers made a big mistake.
The girl in the trunk.
Oh, thank you.
You literally said a super chat?
You said a super chat?
Oh, fuck.
of what's on the screen.
Okay, I'll read it.
It looks like the kidnappers made a big mistake.
Now I can't.
You said to read it out loud.
Okay, sorry, hold on.
Let me take a sip.
Okay.
It looks like the kidnappers made a big mistake.
The girl in the trunk was Detective Jowd's daughter,
Camilla.
Not the minister's daughter.
Dun, dun, dun.
Oh, what is going on here?
What are you guys doing?
When I got back to the Justice Minister's office, things
were getting even more out of hand.
The devastated man was being grilled by the fiery detective
lady.
D-D-B-B!
Thanks for the money.
Oh, that's what she's doing.
She's going off on him.
I told Lynn what I found out about the kidnapping.
That it wasn't the Justice Minister's daughter who had been
abducted.
That the kidnappers had been holed up in...
and Camilla's old house, and that they sensed my presence
and were already gone.
This is a good recap of what just happened.
I hope this caught you up.
But Camilla, why do they have Camilla?
Her father isn't the stupid old justice minister?
I think the stupid old part is a little uncalled for.
Looks like the kidnappers made a mistake somehow.
The poor girl kidnapped for the ransom of her own father's
execution.
That is actually...
I did not think about that.
That's actually really messed up.
That's actually so messed up.
I missed the last stream.
How long did it take Min to get past the minister's puzzle?
I don't remember.
I think about each chapter has taken me like an hour or so.
Or a little longer.
I also talk.
But this is really messed up.
It's just too much!
It's a cruel twist of fate.
I agree.
That just ain't wrong.
and then there are those other twists too like the
kidnappers winding up and and winding up in and using
Camilla's old house as their hideout there's no way it could
be just a coincidence and them sensing my presence they seem
to know about the powers of the dead I just don't understand
any of it I think you're generally decently quick yay thank
you I told you before detective I want you to stand back.
Bang!
Minus 1 HP, minus 1 HP, minus 1 HP.
Who cares about distance at a time like this?
Look, Mr. Minister.
It wasn't your daughter that was kidnapped.
Don't try to pretend you didn't hear what we were saying.
Ah!
How can you bel- how can I believe in you?
I'm a realist.
Please!
Minus 1 HP.
If you don't believe what we said see for yourself.
Just call home and... I tried calling a hundred times.
My wife won't answer.
She won't?
It's complicated.
Oh, why does life have to be such a complicated thing?
I don't remember the voice I gave him before.
And I feel like I remember Lynn being British, but I think
that was just a Mandela effect.
But if she doesn't have it, doesn't answer, doesn't that
mean everything's normal?
prove it and everyone knows ghosts aren't real why would you
say that what what why would you say that
excuse you and i'm being watched i can't have the police go
check for me besides if the execution isn't carried out
tonight the hostage will be killed what difference does it
make that it's not my daughter i guess that's kind of true
Woo-wee!
That's quite a pickle, Mr. Minister.
Quite a pickle.
Oh, my God.
Here comes the Elvis guy.
I forgot his name.
Miss me, baby.
Oh, Inspector Cabanella.
I thought it was like a pasta.
I was like Carbonaro, but it didn't seem right.
He's so cool.
Ooh, ooh.
Oh, I have a little rapport for you, Mr. Minister.
Oh, my goodness.
If you guys don't bow that deep when you greet me.
Hmm.
The escaped prisoner has been apprehended.
I thought you might like to see him, so here he is.
Wait, he's here?
Oh.
Come on in.
Oh my god, he's just here!
Detective Jowd?
Detective Jowd, I'm so sorry, I tried.
I'm a nerd, you think I could bend like that?
Start, start, start stretching.
Wilson Channel, welcome to membership, thank you!
I know that you're innocent, I just can't prove it.
I'm so sorry.
Lynn please don't apologize to me the reason I don't give
him a voice is I think he's just too cool for I can't do it
justice you know the beautiful love between a teacher and
student it brings a tear to my eye
trick time oh what are they saying you knew didn't you
inspector Carbonara but The execution was tonight.
It's the Giga Chen.
Give him snake voice.
I was planning to doggies up for the meet and greet, but
alas.
Ah, man.
It's okay.
I'm the maid.
I have to be bowing to you.
You guys don't bow to me.
I bow to you guys.
Even if you're just wisps.
You're all Goshujin-sama and Ojo-sama wisps.
Sorry, I was chewing.
I don't believe I had any obligation to tell you.
What a jerk.
And you're fine with this?
I mean, you know as well as I do.
Detective Jowd could never have done such a thing.
No, come on, baby.
I know no such thing.
Huh?
I know two things.
Every time it elongates his words, I want to, like, say it
like a sheep.
Two things to be true, and two things only.
One, he was given the death penalty, and two, he tried to
escape.
What else could I do but haul him in, baby?
But he's an innocent man!
If that's the case, why did you bring him here?
Whatever do you mean, young lady?
He escaped from prison, right?
So why didn't you just take him back to the prison?
you only brought him here to brag about your accomplishment
isn't that right inspector oh Elvis sheep with all these
cool character voices have you ever considered being a
dungeon master I don't I've never ever once had the thought
for your own selfish reasons oh yes call them out call them
out this Guy's a jerk.
So are all those rumors about you true?
That the only thing you care about is a spotless record?
Is that more important to you than saving a friend?
Shots.
Everybody has certain principles they care and to go back
on.
Including me.
You'll understand that someday, baby.
I don't like him.
That's enough, Lin.
Oh.
Talk to, like, a snake, right?
But Detective Jowd!
I'm a death...
It doesn't fit him.
I'm a death row in me.
Who escaped from prison.
It just doesn't fit him at all.
This is how it should be.
But...
The instant fold.
Oh, my ghost!
Oh, I don't want to talk to you.
oh my god we can talk to everybody here it's kind of crazy
you know we'll start with the we'll start with this guy my
poor amelie is she all right actually the girl who was
kidnapped is named camilla why is a dream talking to me in
my head again wait a minute amelie wait they all can
communicate they can all go into the death area together
Interesting.
Could that be the Amelie next door?
Yes, I think so.
Wow, I didn't know the justice minister lived next door.
No, not me.
My wife.
It's complicated.
Yeah, I bet it would be pretty hard to admit she...
Wait, there's no secrets in the ghost world, Sissel!
Ghost Skype.
Oh.
Sissel.
He never learns.
Actually, you know what?
Let everybody know.
The minister's wife ran away on him.
Why was she so happy about that?
Yo, is this Professor Layton versus Ace Attorney?
Yes.
Maybe they grew apart.
What, with him being so busy?
Yeah, I bet you're right.
Please stop gossiping about me inside my own head!
According to what I heard, Amelie was supposed to go to some
sort of lesson tonight.
Those horrible kidnappers!
They were lying in wait for her!
But Amelie didn't go out after all.
She couldn't.
She had a fever.
Huh.
And so the kidnappers grabbed Camilla by mistake.
mistake instead?
Apparently.
Emily and Camilla are about the same age.
The kidnappers must have gotten the two of them mixed up.
It's my fault.
If I hadn't asked Camilla to do that errand for me, this
never would have happened.
Oh, right.
You asked her to bring the music box.
Camilla.
Aw, it's not your fault.
It's not your fault.
Alright, let's go talk to Jowd.
Mr. Ghost, do we meet again?
I hear something happen.
Something about it kidnapping.
It's your daughter!
Some kidnappers are saying they abducted the Justice
Minister's daughter.
That's terrible.
What's their demand?
The carrying out of your execution tonight.
Ha ha ha!
I had no idea I was so hated.
But the Minister doesn't have to worry.
die and it's all over very simple no what about your
daughter it's not that simple why not because it isn't
really the minister's daughter who got kidnapped it's
camilla you just spat food all over if you could choose to
someone's life with wait choose to what with ghost trick but
in exchange they could hear what you think when you talk to
them What would you do, Ghost Maid?
What, like, save someone's life with the ghost trick?
Um...
Yeah, save.
But, like, what if the death is, like, really interesting?
Really creative.
Kind of, like, the death contraption.
Can we hear your thoughts?
What would you want to hear, huh?
What would you... What do you think that I think, in my
head, that I don't say out loud.
99% of the time.
What do you think that I'm thinking about, Snake?
Lude thoughts.
Exactly my point.
What do you think that I'm thinking about that I do not say
90...
You know what?
I'll even...
I might drop it a little.
95% of the time.
I have nothing to lose, man, with a young daughter.
I know, right?
Hmm.
Nerd stuff.
You know deep down that you're actually cute.
I wish.
I wish I could agree with you there.
Anyway.
Camilla.
I checked it out for myself.
I'm positive.
No, it can't be.
By the way, Camilla told me something interesting.
She said the one who killed her mother five years ago...
...was Camilla herself!
What?
What are you talking about?
Don't listen to him!
I'm the one who shot her!
I'm the one who shot Alma!
And when I'm executed tonight, that will be the end of it.
Camilla won't have to suffer anymore after tonight.
She's suffering because...
Camilla, she was a baby!
What do you think she's going to get the death penalty?
This guy is so backwards.
For a capable detective, you say some incredibly misguided
things.
Yeah, her dad is going to die, and that means her dad and
her mom are going to be dead.
How is that going to end her suffering?
This guy is so stupid.
You dying isn't going to end that girl's suffering.
It'll just bring her new suffering.
the only person's pain this execution is going to ease is
yours
do you think the lamp was the mom the lamp at the very
beginning but also facts sisal facts do you think the lamp
do you think the mom is what protected is what protected
Camilla from dying before mmm
That's what I was thinking.
Great minds.
But I'm just cooking.
No confirming or denying.
We're cooking together, everybody.
Is it true?
What Camilla said?
Why don't you tell us what you know?
The murder five years ago.
To be honest, I still don't understand what happened that
day.
It was my wife's almost birthday.
The lamp is me.
I'm the game.
I believe you being quake.
Sorry.
Being quake.
We came home from work.
And she went in first.
Oh yeah, that's true.
She did die a long time ago.
And he said that...
Or the lamp said that...
You only get...
But what if that's not actually the case?
What if that's not actually the case?
What if the lamp lied?
What if the lamp lied so that we would solve the case
tonight?
So that we would have a motive?
Because the lamp seemed to know a lot.
But if they were only around for a little bit of time, they
wouldn't know so much.
What if the lamp is the mom trying to save the dad?
Because she knows that it wasn't him.
Why would a lamp lie?
I looked for the shooter, but there was nobody to be found.
There was nobody there besides Alma and Camilla.
Just the two of them.
So the little lady's mother died right in front of her.
So sad.
That's so horrible.
Camilla told me about it.
She was crying.
Lamp has grandpa voice, though.
You're so right.
What was I thinking?
The lamps of Grandpa.
I have a big question, though.
Who is Cicel?
I know, we still don't know.
But we gotta get to the music box, and then we'll figure it
all out.
She said the contraption she made did something it wasn't
supposed to.
Made an impossible move.
An impossible move.
I love, I love, you know what, maybe Cicel needs the snake
voice, since he talks like snake.
The powers of the dead.
It's been five years since then.
I stopped thinking about it.
I shot Alma.
There's no other explanation.
That's what I'd convince everyone of.
Even me.
But tonight, you showed up and gave me an explanation I
never would have thought of before.
The powers of the dead, right?
That day in that room, powers that I didn't understand were
at work.
And if that's the case, it clears up...
all the mysteries so a ghost that doesn't save lives but
kills lives oh my god an
evil ghost maybe not all there are a couple of other people
who know about those powers her is somebody there can you
hear me I can sense your presence you know the kidnappers
the kidnappers knew wait the kidnappers who abducted camilla
knew about those powers this is no ordinary kidnapping it
looks like my wife's case isn't coming to an end after all
i'm the only one who thought it was yeah liquid sizzle
detective out there's still time before dawn a little anyway
how about you see this case through to the end before you
die I only know one other ghost mint what have you been up
to on the side well
you know a little here a little kind of like you know a
little uh this and that right and left up and down hmm that
sock that went missing last week on the dark web being sold
uh you know that cake you were saving but disappeared all of
a sudden hmm yeah you ate it but i possess you when you're
dead.
Officer, there's ghosts right here.
No, no, no!
I'm innocent.
No, no, no, no.
I'm innocent, I promise.
I didn't do a thing.
I didn't miss this.
It wasn't me.
An impossible move.
Camilla was a quiet little girl, but she was good with her
hands.
She was a little genius.
She's a little genius.
At making elaborate toys and contraptions.
But there were two very strange points about that
contraption.
No, don't put me next to the police!
The first was, of course, the firing of that gun.
Right.
That was an antique gun I had on display for years.
So it wasn't part of the little lady's original design.
Of course it wasn't!
It was supposed to be a surprise for her mother's birthday!
And the other strange point was the movement of that cupid.
Cupid.
Yeah, the poppers were supposed to go up.
It was supposed to shoot its arrow without turning around.
Why did it turn around?
Just like that.
Maybe, maybe we avoid having contraptions with using fire,
you know, and that girl's name, Albert Einstein.
Somebody made a change to the contraptions design and then
manipulated it.
I don't know what to say.
I didn't have time to think things through then.
All I knew was I had to protect Camilla.
I made a small adjustment to the scene and turned to myself.
off it.
Adjustment to the scene.
What kind of an adjustment?
The gun, of course.
The gun, eh?
Come to think of it.
Oh yeah, it was missing.
There was no gun there.
Just a picture hanging on the wall.
Of course not.
Because I secretly switched the gun out of that frame with
the picture.
Oh.
I didn't believe what she told me about her contraption.
Why did you believe her?
But one thing was for certain.
That gun was still smoking.
So that gun really did you, Alma.
I hid the gun before I went to the police.
You hid it?
I put it in a wooden box and gave it to a certain detective.
Me?
Or her?
Wait, is it in the music box?
You mean...
Ah!
Still thinks it's a music box!
So that's... Oh my gosh, you just gave her a gun.
Dang.
So that's what was in the box, huh?
I got a different murder weapon ready to give to the police.
My own pistol.
And I did a few other... But...
No, that doesn't make any sense.
If you give your own pistol to the police, the bullets
wouldn't match up.
You said it was an antique gun.
That's the evidence that you need!
The bullets wouldn't match up!
keep reading read his line oh and i did a few other things
to make it look good i won't go into the details when i was
all done i turned myself in oh he said that it matched oh he
did wait Huh?
Maybe he shot the corpse?
Oh, we did a few other things.
That's... what...
That's...
That...
How could you?
Like, even if someone...
Even if someone were dead...
If they were, like, my husband or wife, I wouldn't be able
to reshoot them at all.
What?
oh my god so anyway I started blasting oh my god when I was
all done I turned myself in
wow that that's that's a lot damn I thought I was on to
something too I was just like damn it detective Jowd why'd
you have to be so thorough I was like just go find the
bullet it'll be fine Damn it!
Detective Jowd is what you told us just now true.
Yes, of course.
In that case, there's still time!
Still time.
Time to solve the case that started five years ago.
You didn't do it, Detective Jowd.
Camilla didn't do it either.
So the true perpetrator is still out there, and I'm going to
prove it.
For Camilla's sake!
Whoa.
That sounds wonderful.
Yeah!
He's on our side now!
Thank you, Detective Jowd.
Lynn, where is that music box now?
In Temsik Park.
Camilla left it there.
Wait, don't just yell this out to everybody.
We don't know who we can trust.
That gun is important evidence.
You'd better go pick it up.
Don't just tell everybody!
Yes, sir.
I'll go right now.
Cicel, take care of Detective Jowd.
And do something about the kidnapping so we can get the
minister on our side.
And yet again, I say, easy enough for you to say.
uh is he is that anybody are they not going to be like oh
what what was that what it's going on deal me the deal mr
death row and mate a little change in plans my daughter has
been kidnapped i can't just go off to die without doing
something but you're in our custody don't forget it back at
the prison everybody's you with a special seat just for you,
Rebbe.
Then I guess we'd better prove my innocence on the double.
On the double, is it?
You sound so determined, my old friend.
Hmm.
I want to save Camilla.
In more ways than one.
Yeah!
And that's all there is to it.
Didn't the chair blow up?
It did.
The chair did blow up.
So what are they going to do now?
Oh my god.
They're going to put...
the chicken I see my old friend in more ways than what what
say you mr.
minister maybe have your decision please please mr.
minister should the execution be carried out tonight as
planned or should we hold off and wait for this important
evidence to come in oh it's not your daughter The order
still stands.
This guy sucks.
We should have never saved him.
Poison chicken.
Bring the prisoner back immediately and resume its
enforcement.
No!
As you wish your excellent save.
Oh, my guide.
Please don't bow down to me.
And especially not that low.
In that case, can I...
have one of your booze?
Boy!
Arrange for a prison van to pick him up.
Oh my goodness, I always have boo on the mind.
Would you be so kind?
Yes sir!
Hoop, hoop, hoop.
Where did that come from?
Are you just gonna stare at me?
What are you obsessed with me?
The van should take about 10 minutes, I'm guessing.
Your escape tonight was brilliant.
Will you show me another miracle in these last few minutes
of yours, Mr. Deathrow inmate?
Q Amelia, thanks for a month, VTuber.
Thank you!
Let's see.
We gotta show a miracle, huh?
glad to see Detective Jowd all fired up now I feel like I'm
under the gun here even if Lynn does come through with the
proof of Jowd's innocence it will be meaningless if Jowd or
Camilla dies I've got to do something about that kidnapping
somehow maybe I should ask for some advice from the capable
detective here or we spear him or we spear him let's go get
inside this guy's head um excuse me Mr. Minister I'm gonna
haunt you until the day you die.
I can't hear you, la la la la.
I'm sure you've heard everything we've been saying.
Are you telling me you don't believe any of it?
Let me speak plainly.
I don't trust you.
But there's somebody else whom I trust even less.
Oh yeah?
Who's that?
Me!
I can't explain your existence.
It's not normal.
But I'm pretty abnormal myself.
are a figment of my imagination.
A delusion.
Oh my god.
The voices.
Would you listen to a delusion?
To be honest, I have no idea what you're talking about.
I got the bit about you not trusting me, though.
Most likely, the minister won't stop the execution.
The voices.
The Lulu is the Salulu.
The Salulu.
not as long as there's any small chance his daughter is the
one who was kidnapped but she isn't the one I'm sure of it
well it would be great if we could prove that to the
minister prove it how we have to get them to call we have to
get the wife to call him I doubt his wife is ever going to
answer that phone if we call from here if we call from here
right But a telephone works in both directions.
Yes, yes, yes.
What are you saying?
What I'm saying is only family members can solve a family
problem.
Hey, Mr. Ghost?
Yes.
I have to admit, I don't like depending on others.
But you're the only one who can change the situation.
Gee, detective.
For these past five years, Camilla is the only thing that
kept me going.
I can't go meekly to the chair now.
I hate to ask this but would you mind saving me I'll try the
key to getting the justice minister to stop the execution is
his wife and daughter but is there a way oh my gosh we're
going back to the lady wait can I no it won't let me go
anywhere else okay time to can I knock this off spray little
water pitcher just saved the justice minister's life he
drank all the water so now it's empty I think he should get
it refilled you never know when another fit may visit so
true hanging around here won't change anything I've got ten
minutes before the prison van shows up I could just do
something about the kidnapping in those ten minutes I guess
the telephone lines are my only hope okay let's make it the
best ten minutes of our lives baby ladies red
Stay hydrated, everyone.
Just as I thought.
This little girl is safe in her bed.
She's so cute.
She reminds me of...
Did I say this last time?
She reminds me of Beatrice from Re-Zero.
Murder.
Execution.
Jail break.
Betrayal.
And now kill.
Kidnapping.
This last link in this long chain of a sad fate lit a fire
in Jowd's heart.
I did.
And the chance to turn it all around is right here in this
room.
You guys, if you ever think...
If you ever think I'm not sincere, I always think the same
things.
I always think the same things over and over again.
I love this music so much
I'm getting a strange premonition Everything that happened
so far tonight Has related back to me in some way And I bet
this mistaken Written abduction does too I'm so curious who
Sissel is Oh that was the end of the chapter Oh,
interesting.
We just got this illustration now.
Even though Cabanella tall and lovely.
Well, one of those words describes him as definitely not
tall.
Okay.
Continue playing.
Yeah.
It's only been an hour and a half.
That was a shorter chapter, wasn't it?
I visited the novelist's apartment again.
I'm hoping to be able to do something about this mistaken
identity kidnapping as long as there's any possibility that
it could be his own daughter who was kidnapped I doubt the
justice minister will call off the execution tonight I'm
studying so keep me company me though I'll be here
the key to dispelling the minister's doubts is not now in
bed coughing and I need to use this key and i need to use
this key before that prison van arrives to pick up our death
row inmate oh my god there she's back she's back baby
this poor girl she's so sick my darling angel oh just listen
to that cough you naughty thing did you leave your nice warm
bed to go out into the night to play a daughter after my own
heart but I must confess I didn't even notice you were gone
that's that's not anything to brag about I didn't go out to
play I went to buy Papa a birthday present he said he wanted
a new lighter okay but that's no reason to go out this late
at night.
But my fever finally went down.
I could barely move before that.
But look what it brought you.
Your fever is worse now than ever.
Here is to the feverish passion of my darling angel.
Ding!
31st, bam!
Welcome to my membership, thank you.
Mama.
Yes, darling.
Let's call Papa and wish him a happy birthday, even though
it's already past midnight.
Hmm.
Not tonight, Amelie.
Okay.
I hate you!
Mint coughing, baby.
Shut up!
Shut up, nanoplasm!
I had the lady's voice stuck in my head all day after the
last time you did it.
OMG.
It looks like this little girl was safe all along.
I already knew that, but I'm still relieved.
All the same.
What did I do?
Don't turn my coughs into baby coughs.
Don't turn my coughs into baby cough, baby cough, listening
files.
You!
There's another lucky development, too.
Emily wants to call her father.
I can make use of that feeling somehow.
That would surely bring the Justice Minister around.
Wait, so that's a lighter right there?
Do we have to just light the shelf on fire and have it move
the phone closer to her?
Trick time.
Light it.
Oh, easy.
More arson.
The phone.
Oh, oh.
Don't look it.
Oh, don't look it.
Look.
No, no, no, no, no, no.
Hurry up.
Call.
Amelie, I told you you couldn't call him tonight.
Why not?
Listen to me, Amelie.
Your father is about to make a big mistake.
I want him to reconsider.
Ooh.
What do you know about it, Mama?
He's the one who's the justice minister, you know.
All you do is write weird novels.
what what do you mean weird how dare you disparage my
romantic expressions now you've really made me angry you
really have oh my god
what's wrong with her what happened to her hair How dare you
expect me to forgive such an insult?
It's called Hentai and it's an art.
I knew it wouldn't be so easy.
No!
She's working on milk farm too.
Let her cook then!
There.
I'll be keeping my eye on you now.
So you won't do anything else mischievous.
Like calling your father.
I hate you!
I can hear you, you know.
Ah, hum, hum.
What a pair.
I don't know what this family's issues are, but I do know I
have to do something about this lady so Emily can call.
Fire!
Set it on fire!
Okay, we have the waste basket.
Oh, let's see.
Oh, are we going to start an electrical fire?
Let's start an electrical fire.
Let's see.
What happens if I do this?
Two, two what?
Swing hard.
Two weak.
Look at him go.
Well, I don't know what it's supposed to do, though.
Poor little guy.
What does she say here?
She coughs.
Mama, what is Papa about to do?
Never mind.
Nothing you need to know right now, Amalie.
Why is everything always such a big secret?
I'm part of this family, too, you know.
It's not something for children's ears.
You'll understand someday.
I don't want to know someday.
I want to know now.
It's not fair.
You just don't want to tell me.
I just want to wish Papa a happy birthday.
Not tonight.
If it was up to me, I'd let her call him.
Thanks, Sissel.
How nice.
Hmm.
If he swings harder...
I don't know, let's see.
Let's go back up here.
We turn this.
Hoist.
Turn that.
Examine the dictionary.
The lady's dictionary.
Wasn't this on her desk before?
The poor thing.
Destined to never be returned to the bookshelves.
Hoist.
Hmm.
We turn this valve.
Oh, make it chime.
Ping-bong!
Oh!
Well, well, having a good time.
Are we, little rodent?
Woo!
Yes, mommy.
Sweet dreams!
Ow!
This poor guy...
Wait.
Fancy the vintage, my whiskered friend.
Ding!
Oh!
But it moved over the lamp.
Or not the lamp.
The um...
The chandelier.
The sconce?
The sconce.
She's more powerful than I thought.
It looks like she tipped the wall.
Oh, candelabra.
The candelabra to one side too.
Hmm, the angle of those candles.
I get the feeling I've seen something very similar to that
quite recently.
Yes, we have.
I better not put out the lamp right now.
It will only pour oil on the flames of anger in this lady's
heart.
If I want to give Amelia a chance to use the telephone, I
have to think of a way to keep her mother out of the way.
So we turn the rat to the other side and we get her to turn
around.
turn turn turn there we go oh oh my god this poor rat no
this poor rat oh oh heaven's a blackout at a critical time
like this of course dim lights suit my story of love very
well but i myself am not very fond of the dark is the rat
okay This chandelier just narrowly missed the back of my
head.
I love the thrill of romance, but I don't need these kinds
of thrills.
Thank you.
I forgot that she lights it with her ass.
Oh, she's going to drink that.
Ah, what a wonderful atmosphere.
Perfect for a clandestine meeting in the dusky twilight.
Trick time.
I don't exactly know how this situation came about.
But I think I owe that rat an apology.
The rat seems to be unconscious.
But now that the room has changed into this, maybe I can use
it somehow.
Yes.
So the rat...
If I crank this...
Oh!
My goodness.
What a naughty chandelier.
Sorry, ma'am.
Sorry, I'm so naughty.
I'm naughty.
I'm a naughty chandelier.
If the rat died, you'd have to go back in time to save it.
You're right.
Do I open this?
It doesn't do anything.
I can't tell if I'm being timed here or not.
You know?
Swing harder?
No.
Burn brighter!
Whoa!
Wow.
We need to get something to swing on the clock, maybe.
Or...
If I lower it...
The
music is relaxing.
It is kind of making me sleepy.
I'm not gonna lie.
Why turn this again?
It doesn't do anything.
The lights are out, so it doesn't really matter anyway.
Um...
Nothing there.
Something related to the dictionary?
Let's try it.
The lady's dictionary.
Wasn't this on the disc before?
Yep, nope.
And I can't reach anything over on the other side.
I don't think they have anything to do with it this time.
Can I get her hair?
When she leans back!
Oh, dang.
That was close.
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
Drop it!
Whoa!
Such insolence!
Okay, a little bit more.
That was close too.
I want to see what Cicel says about it.
Twice she managed to dodge like that.
Who knew she was such a dodging champion?
I'm starting to get annoyed.
Let me try that again.
I'll get her this time.
She's too good.
She is.
Walk, walk, walk.
Help me!
Oh,
oh, oh.
I'm sorry, Mama.
I'm too dizzy.
I can't get up.
I'm afraid I can't help you right now.
Here?
It's to the weakness of my darling angel.
Ding!
That chandelier is on there tighter than her wedding band.
She won't be able to escape on her own.
Crank?
Oh my god, this is kind of messed up.
What is going on here?
Emily, look.
Do you see this?
Help me, please.
Sorry.
I'm too sick.
I can't get out of bed.
What is going on?
My head is...
What?
Oh, no.
She doesn't have his other accent.
My head is spinning.
So I guess I'll just have to stay up there spinning too.
Um...
Oh.
Looks like this lady won't be going anywhere for a while.
Now the little girl can call her father.
Yeah, but we still have to get her to reach the phone.
The only trouble is she can't reach it.
Guess I'll just have to deliver it to her.
Wait.
That's right.
The angle of those candles.
I saw something very similar just recently, didn't I?
Yeah, yeah.
So if I burn brighter...
Excuse me, ma'am.
Oh my god!
Oh, okay, okay, okay.
And then...
Wait.
Swing harder.
Swing harder!
Oh!
It got the ride.
Oh, there we go.
I had a feeling that I might be the rat.
Now I really owe that poor rat an apology.
This might be a really good chance for me, too.
I have to get that phone to Ameli.
Okay, swing harder, swing harder.
Oh my god.
This is chaos.
This is absolute chaos.
Arson, arson, arson, arson.
There we go.
Mama!
What in the world?
world is going on
i think we're over it now everything is all good oh my
goodness why was it so shaky troy enters the room with pizza
literally that meme yes oh goody excuse me a minute while i
call papa okay mama i'll only be a minute
don't you dare omelette Uh, get me down!
Sorry, I'm reading.
Hello, Papa.
Oh, Millie.
You know what's kind of messed up about this situation?
Is...
You know, it's kind of like what he said.
Even if it's not his daughter that's been kidnapped.
There's still a daughter, or still someone that...
It's still a young girl that has been kidnapped.
That...
the the the ransom is the death of the guy but he's just
like well it's not my daughter so I guess it doesn't matter
if she dies is that you of course it is silly what did you
think but I heard they said you were no no never mind it's
nothing silly old papa happy birthday papa birthday oh right
it was my birthday today wasn't it i'm sorry we couldn't
celebrate tonight thanks to mean old mama what's even sadder
is this rat's life oh your mean old mama i mean your mother
what is she up to right now oh she's up all right
I don't know how this keeps happening
She's reading the script No Oh my god Yo I thought this was
a blind playthrough I don't This game is just mint coded I
don't know what else to tell you guys Okay This game is mint
if your name shows up in the credits It's just It's just
extremely mint coded Okay.
You're awesome.
Oh, you need to stop doing this.
It's not funny anymore.
I'm scared.
I'm scared too.
Maybe this is the ghost trick all along.
Okay, so we'll come back.
Thank you and hybrid.
Welcome back.
Stop reading.
I'm not reading.
I'm a real Ace Attorney fan.
It's true.
Oh, man.
Ghost to ghost communication.
Okay.
Oh, my stubborn mother is kind of tied up at the moment.
Get me down.
She needs to be taught a lesson for causing us so much
trouble.
Angelic descent, welcome to Mambusha.
Mint, are you the lamp?
No, Amelie.
Is it you?
Are you the baddie?
I'm the one who is wrong.
Hey, what's in the sand?
Is that the script?
You could have lived if you played this game within four
minutes of your own death, and you're right!
Huh?
Could you tell your mother I'm sorry?
What do you have to be sorry about?
Can I have the lottery numbers?
If you're a shoe Takumi, can we have another Edgeworth game?
I was just about to make a terrible mistake.
right now.
Oh!
Oh my god, his face all of a sudden.
Oh, he's actually kind of handsome.
Oh, okay.
You're still young.
There's a lot I can't tell you right now.
The job of Justice Minister is very complicated, you see.
Yeah, he lost all of his wrinkles instantly.
Okay.
But just remember, you're always the most important thing to
your mother and me.
Did you do something naughty to your mother.
If you did, I want you to apologize.
I don't think I did anything.
But okay, I'll apologize.
That's a good girl.
Okay, Papa.
Have a good night.
I love you.
I love you too, Amelie.
Have a good night, sweetheart.
Then that was that.
Maybe you should call the police.
Uh, Mama?
I'm sorry.
My goodness, why are the change.
I guess I was wrong about you.
I didn't understand.
Oh, Amelie.
Yeah, and the fire department.
I thought all you ever did was write these weird novels.
That makes me a little sad.
Papa said the job of Justice Minister was complicated.
Yes, your father's job is very, very complicated and
difficult.
That's why I couldn't talk to you about most of it.
you're right i couldn't i shouldn't treat you like such a
little girl anymore you're growing up after all and i
promise to stop calling your novels weird and try actually
read oh no no no no no don't read them what oh uh maybe you
better wait until you're a little older for that oh okay so
amily if you're feeling a little more charitable towards
your old mama do you think you could let me down You know, I
would love to do that.
But I'm just feeling too dizzy and sick right now.
Oh.
Tonight, on this holiest of nights, my deadline.
It looks like the only thing pressing on me will be this
chandelier.
Here's the Papa and Mama's darling angel.
Ding.
That thing is so...
It's so...
What's the word?
so sturdy it's holding her up so well all of a sudden
everybody is getting along again it's such an abrupt change
I can't understand it is this what family is all about in
any case the situation has changed dramatically now I just
hope the mysteries of me can be cleared up as quickly as the
furrows of on the ministers bro I wish I was that chandelier
pun pun you keep you keep you keep dreaming you know never
let go of that dream.
Think about how you want to be the chandelier in this very
moment and never let go of that feeling.
Thank God if only if only I were the chandelier tightly
tightly grasping a grown woman's waist her bosom too big to
fit through her butt her bottom too big as well just keep
about that as your dream just keep thinking about it and
never let go because that is what dreams are made of
I don't know where Camilla is at least now the justice
minister's doubts are dispelled I think I'll go back to his
office where everybody is waiting for the prison van oh
don't tell me we got there and he already got picked up
never let go of the bosom or the bottom Be the chandelier.
I'll toast to that.
Top and bottom's big because they're filled with our dreams.
Exactly, exactly, exactly.
Mint, I'm stuck in my dreams.
Dream.
Keep dreaming.
Don't let go of the dreams.
Just keep living.
Live and dream.
The minister's family now has their smiles and harmony back.
But Camilla is still in the hands of the Lord.
of the kidnappers.
I decided to go back to the Justice Minister's office.
Oisha.
the Minister's brow is still just as furrowed as ever.
Quite unlike a father who had just learned his daughter is
safe, he seems to still be in the depths of despair.
That atmosphere in this room is very different now.
It seems to have an air of unfocused anxiety.
I get the feeling something big is about to happen.
I just found out that my daughter is safe.
I'd like to express my gratitude.
Thank you.
Thank you for my daughter's sake.
And for mine.
Oh, ha, who?
No need to thank us, Mr. Minister.
It was nothing.
You didn't do anything.
What did he do?
Well, one question.
I can't help but notice.
Your daughter is safe.
And yet you still look unhappy.
a little smile for us ah of course there is still the matter
of the other kidnapping victim but is that really the only
thing that troubles you mr minister
oh please let me think in peace until the prison van arrives
what no no no come on man I wonder if Lynn is back at the
park yet.
Until we get her report, I guess we'll just have to wait
here.
This continued distress of the ministers.
Is there really something more to it, like the inspector in
white said?
Yeah, let's see what he says now.
Oh, because also, he's...
Is he, like, probably, like, getting blackmailed by the blue
people or something, you know?
Hold on.
Hello, Justice Minister.
How about you finally admit I do exist?
That thank you I expressed.
That was meant for you.
You're a ghost, aren't you?
And you have the power to control and manipulate people,
don't you?
No, I don't have that kind of power.
I can't control you.
Ghost?
We've actually known you, you know, for quite a while now.
They were the powers of the dead, of ghosts.
Known.
Wait, known about what?
We knew about the existence of somebody who could control
others.
A manipulator.
What's this?
That's why your execution order caused me so much anguish,
Detective Jowd.
Mr. Minister.
Why don't you just tell us everything you know?
Is that why they're in the special prison?
Is everybody in the special prison?
affected by these manipulating cases?
So they might be innocent, but like...
They were manipulated?
Hmm.
I suppose I should.
QMalia!
Thanks for the five gifted.
Thank you!
You need to hear it all.
All about the huge mistake this foolish man made.
Manipulator.
There are some cases in this country right now that are
under a top-secret investigation!
Of course you wouldn't have known about them, Detective
Jaur.
Right, they don't share too much top-secret information with
the inmates in prison.
There are three prisoners, including you and the special
prison you've just escaped from.
All three cases have certain points in common.
They do, do they?
Tell us more.
I knew it!
The rock singer who leaked national secrets in his lyrics
during a TV broadcast.
The curry-loving fellow who took the chief commissioner
hostage at the Metro Police Department.
Neither of these men had a motive for their crime, and both
of their crimes were impossible.
Impossible.
The curry lover had no way of knowing how to infiltrate the
commissioner's office.
And the rock singer had no way of knowing the national
secrets he leaked.
Sausage head.
The special investigation unit?
submitted an investigative report to me on them.
It concluded that these men's criminal acts were not of
their own volition.
But how could that be?
The theory the unit came up with was the existence of a
manipulator.
A manipulator, huh?
Ghost that saves lives and ghost that kills wives.
That's when the special prison was established as a facility
to research that theory.
It would make sense then why she has the sixth sense, right?
Because if they're working with the bad ghost, if they're
working with a bad ghost, she would have the ability to
sense ghosts, you know?
Sorry, I was chewing.
Um.
That's when the special prison was established as a facility
to research that theory.
Jowd's case.
work.
These past several years, Inspector Cabanela has been
studying these cases.
He has, has he?
Manipulating somebody into committing a criminal act.
According to the inspector, hmm?
Wow, Joshua!
Firmly grasped the ghost.
Thank you for the outcome so far!
Thank you!
Thank you, thank you, thank you!
Thank you so much.
I really appreciate it.
of its kind was a locked room murder involving our nation's
best detective.
Are you saying I was somehow manipulated?
Or are you trying to say I was manipulated somehow into
shooting Alma?
I appreciate the theory, but unfortunately, I don't recall
being controlled by anybody.
It's just not possible to manipulate another's behavior like
that.
My powers certainly don't work on living creatures.
That's what I thought when I first heard the theory, too.
However, I was seriously mistaken, and it proved to be a big
mistake.
What?
Okay, the minister's mistake.
You mentioned a mistake.
Could you tell us about it?
I suppose everybody here has the right to know.
All right, fine.
I'll speak out.
Can you just Inspector Cavanella is like sitting in this
room in silence while they're probably all like...
locked in in this conversation in their brain.
All right, fine.
I'll speak out loud so that Inspector Cabanela can hear this
too.
Oh, interesting, okay.
Everyone's using codecs.
It's the go, it's the godeck.
It's the ghost codeck.
There's something I'd like the two of you to hear.
It's about a mistake I made.
Inspector Cabanilla, when you first made that report about a
manipulator, I'm afraid I didn't believe it at all.
Impossible, I thought.
Perfectly understandable, Mr. Minister.
But I was wrong.
That kind of power does exist.
And I...
I learned the truth of that firsthand.
What's this?
A month ago, I signed the order to carry out Detective
Jowd's execution.
However, that act wasn't of my own volition.
I was being controlled.
What?
You never told me about this, Mr. Minister?
What's going on?
This document?
What am I doing?
No, I mustn't sign it.
Oh, oh.
Oh!
Why is he clapping?
What's going on?
Wait, did he sign it?
Oh no!
Wait, don't deliver that document!
Oh, I guess she just doesn't listen to you.
That's when it started.
That's when all of my fear, despair, and suffering began.
Oh my god, he must be so paranoid.
Oh.
Fear, fear, despair, and suffering.
At the time, it didn't even cross my mind that I had been
manipulated.
And my memory of the event was only hazy at best.
So the memory of being manipulated doesn't clearly remain,
eh?
Signing execution orders is part of a justice minister's
job.
At the time, I just thought my psyche was rebelling against
the task.
through this arm I live but the next day it dawned on me I
remembered Inspector Cabanilla's report on the existence of
a manipulator oh as the Minister of Justice I couldn't admit
what had happened to me I only signed the execution order
because I was being controlled oh sorry there's something
like that got out this nation's judicial system would
crumble besides I had no evidence to present that I had
actually been controlled.
One month haunting.
Thank you.
So in the end, I couldn't admit to anybody what had
happened.
Hmm, I suppose.
But it sounds like a bit of an excuse.
You should have at least told us, Mr. Minister.
Noat, thank you.
Sounds awfully familiar to the tale of someone eating cake
with no memory of it, huh?
Uh...
Um...
Anyway.
Next question.
Psycho Mantis.
Oh my gosh, Joshua.
Thank you for the ping.
Thank you.
Cool guy.
Welcome back.
Thank you.
Yes.
Yes, I know.
I should have.
I was running away from the problem.
Psycho Mantis.
His wife.
And then my wife found out I was worried about something
well if you go around with an expression like that I guess
it's bound to happen I explained it to her she was dead set
against the way I was handling it oh she has whoa if you
don't withdraw that order and tell everybody the truth
immediately I'm moving out oh she's a she's a feisty woman
and then with the kidnapping tonight with it thrust under my
nose like that I could make no longer deny my mistake
What's this?
Some mysterious force has my wallet.
Evan, welcome back.
Send out mistakes with Supertet.
This manipulator comes upon us from somewhere unseen.
That's why I've been keeping my distance from everybody.
So that's why you've been telling people to stay back.
So there's somebody else besides me with the powers of the
dead.
I'm fine with that.
After all, I already knew about a certain desk lamp.
Yeah.
What I'm not fine with is the fact that person can control
and manipulate living creatures.
That's certainly not something I can do.
Apparently, different ghosts get different ghost tricks.
See, I just don't have the correct ghost trick, you guys.
I just don't have the correct ghost trick.
It's...
It could have been me.
But I never imagined that tonight.
I would find out where this kind of power comes from where
it comes from ghosts inspector cabanella this manipulator is
a ghost a departed spirit a specter a spirit as a matter of
fact there's a ghost talking to us right now oh what what
did you say ciao don't tell me you can hear this ghost too
uh i'd say the only person who can't hear him is you Spirit,
ghost, gods, and heaven.
Excuse me, Mr. Minister, I suddenly have some urgent
business to attend to.
That's kind of sussy, isn't it?
I'm being manipulated to send the Supa.
I can't control my actions.
To Chonky, no!
I recommend you think long and hard before making your final
decisions.
There you go, it's trotting away.
He didn't even, he didn't even dance.
Is that Lynn?
Hmm.
Well, I'm eating.
This is Lynn.
I'm at the park.
Oh, Lynn.
Uh-oh.
Lynn's about to get kidnapped, isn't she?
Lynn's about to get kidnapped.
We've been waiting for to hear from you.
Have you found the evidence?
Well, the situation in here is, It's kind of difficult to
explain.
Cicel, if you're there, come to the park immediately.
Uh-oh.
Well, somebody died.
It looks like your help is needed, Cicel.
This is a normal super chat.
I am not being manipulated.
That's something someone being manipulated wouldn't say.
Someone being manipulated would say I'm being manipulated.
You're definitely not being manipulated.
Yeah, I guess so, huh?
Let's go to the park!
Park.
Yippee!
I'm being manipulated.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no.
I think the Chonky is onto something.
Your ghost trick is making us send mint-colored Supas.
Help!
Lynn calls and I oblige.
I take off towards Temsika Park, a place where clearly
something big is taking place.
Skye, please, thank you for that question, bro.
I am in full control of myself.
All my faculties are working without issue nor impediment.
The bank will not decline the payment request.
I will remember exactly what I've done with no regret.
There is no negative influence on my person at this moment.
I'm not blinking.
Thank you for that question, bro.
That totally was not manipulated out of you.
Thank you.
The guards don't say anything.
They've been there all along for everything.
Are they deaf?
You know what?
Don't worry about them.
It's like the guards at, you know, the palace and stuff.
They're not allowed to, they're not allowed to, you know,
interact.
It's like a person on a nature documentary.
You just watch from the distance.
Fukuro, thanks for the 550.
Stupid shark.
It's happening here too.
Thank you.
There must be a manipulator on every turn.
Every time I turn on my gacha.
Oh, probably.
Oh my gosh, say that!
Am I...
Many...
Pull...
Layden?
No, no.
I guess it works.
Man, gotcha, or something.
Man, many, many pull...
Layden.
I don't know that word.
Strange.
Too strange.
I'm sorry.
Sorry.
I think I've missed so many words since I've been...
dead?
You know, my memory is kind of, you know.
Hayden, thanks for the five gifted!
Alright, let's go to Temsik Park, everybody.
The manipulator.
The person whose very existence sheds new light on
everything.
Detective Jowd's crime.
The execution orders, and even my own death.
Could it be?
Could Lynn have been manipulated into shooting me?
Oh!
I completely forgot that was an element!
Oh my gosh!
Boy, oh my gosh.
Thank you guys for all the super chats.
Thank you!
Thank you guys.
That song was called To Nothingness?
How many, what chapter are we on?
I can't remember.
It was 13 now?
14!
14 out of...
Um...
Out of 18, right?
I wonder if I should just power through today.
I wonder if I should just power it through today.
Was this sending a message while resisting?
I'm being manipulated.
No, no, no.
You wanted to send that.
Nice progress.
Don't you have something big tomorrow?
Do I?
I don't think so.
Let me check my calendar.
Oh, I don't know what I just did.
Uh, no.
Wait, tomorrow's Wednesday.
The rest is long.
Hmm.
If I do four more chapters, one hour each about, there'll be
four more hours.
Time is it?
Hmm, might be into the middle of the night.
Hmm.
After this chapter is the best stopping point.
I'm not being manipulated.
Ah!
Wait until after this chapter if you want to decide to
finish.
The upcoming puzzle is probably the hardest in the game.
Okay.
All right.
Cool, cool, cool.
Then we'll decide for this puzzle after.
Okay.
Ghosted notes?
What's the...
Boo!
What kind of stationary does a ghost use?
Ghosted notes!
Okay, maybe we'll do this chapter and then we'll save it for
tomorrow.
I could probably finish it tomorrow, then.
Temsik Park.
The site of the little lady Camilla's abduction tonight.
And the place where an important piece of evidence, the
music box was hidden.
Oh, wow, we're on the whole other side.
I wonder why our lady detective is looking so dejected.
At least she isn't dead.
But what did she find?
Hmm.
Okay.
Oh, it's the chicken, it's the kitchen, chicken, chicken
kitchen man.
What's he doing here?
Let me spend a moment's time with you, la-la-la.
The world will not end if the food delivery is a little
late, la-la-la.
A little late.
It's already ice cold.
Oh my god, this guy sucks.
Oh,
you have to wait for him to get closer to us.
There we go.
Swing harder.
Basketball.
Oh, there's a basketball in there.
Lobe.
Boot.
Leaflet.
Love letter.
Ow.
Oh.
Leaflet, umbrella.
Da-da-da-da.
Rugby.
Um...
Spin?
Baseball.
Wait, there we go.
Seesaw.
Ooh, I got this thing spinning pretty fast.
I didn't even put much effort into it.
There's quite a bit of power and speed for a piece of
playground equipment.
I can just imagine all the poor kids who get sent flying all
over the park.
That's what I'm thinking.
Hello, I'm here!
Oof!
Wait!
Oh, I saw it!
I saw a dead person!
Oh, they were on the far left!
Oh, there you are, Sissel.
From your dejected expression, I gather, you didn't find
what you were looking for.
Right, I can't find the music box anywhere.
But I found something else instead.
Something horrible.
Horrible.
What is it?
A dead body!
Oh!
There in the grass.
You'd better see for yourself.
Looks like a dead body.
I nearly died when I saw it.
And I suppose now that we found it, we can't just leave it
there, can we?
Nope, I suppose not.
Oh, oh, oh, mascot.
All right, let's make connection.
Stop reading ahead.
What do you mean?
Oh, it's this guy.
I forgot about him.
Stop the park from being turned into a housing site.
Protect the park.
The rock of the gods.
You there.
You're talking to me, aren't you?
for you.
Leafless, I know you'll be very interested in.
I urge you to pursue or peruse it thoroughly.
Examine it in detail.
Never mind that right now.
Do you remember your name?
My name.
What does my name matter when there are more important
things to worry about?
She speaks for the rocks.
Okay.
Come now and study these trucks with me my brother come and
learn about the rock of the gods with me the night is no
longer young as a matter of fact daybreak is approaching but
we are young it only just turned 12 look I don't have time
to get involved in your way of life but I am interested
about your way of death so let's go back back to four
minutes before your death oh my god it's been a since we've
since we've done a like this whole stream we haven't we
haven't gone back in time I think he got crushed by the by
the gods wait this is a long time ago and so I made up my
mind I resolved to live here in the park and defend it okay
and what does that have to do with this rock of the gods you
mentioned Yeah, 825pm.
You still don't appear to understand.
No wonder this one is probably hard.
It's written quite clearly in the fourth leaflet.
In great detail.
Excuse me, but I have to use the restroom.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Oh, this is when she gets kidnapped.
I'm coming!
Just one!
I'll be right there!
Oh!
I'm looking in the door at me!
Oh, oh, he took it!
Yes, my dear, I'll ever so gently nap her and come right
back to your side.
Dang it, Shaggy.
It's all your fault.
Oh, he's gonna, like, hit the lever, isn't he?
Good evening, young lady.
Won't you come with me?
Ew!
Oh my god, sorry.
Oh!
Shaggy!
Oh my god.
Wait.
That guy... Wait.
The hippie is actually wearing Shaggy's clothes.
Oh, guys.
What do I do?
What should I do?
I have to do something.
Oh!
Is this where she died?
Oh my god.
Wait.
We have to ghost trick.
We have to ghost trick to stop someone else's ghost trick no
way what in the world just happened oh that's Mino Mino Mino
the mascot the symbol of Temsik Park forget about the name
of that big creepy lump above concrete talking about the way
it changed direction did you see that yes yes I did and we
witnessed it with our eyes.
The power of the rock of the gods.
That was the power of the gods.
The power of the gods saved that little girl.
And then that same power very deliberately crushed you
instead?
You gotta ghost the ghost trick.
Yes, yes precisely.
That is called the mischief of the gods.
This is how Shaggy's parents met.
What?
It couldn't have been a ghost trick.
No ghost trick could change the direction of something that
heavy in mid-air.
But wait a minute.
What if there was somebody with much greater powers than me?
There's another flame besides mine!
Oh, is that the flame of a god, is it?
But hold on.
Your spirit is a flame, too, isn't it?
Yeah, so?
Oh, pardon me, but are you a god?
I knew he was gonna ask that.
Because I read the script.
I sincerely doubt it.
Brother!
The last minute that big lump of concrete made a huge swing
to one side.
That was probably that Flame's doing.
Who could it be?
It's not Missile, is it?
I definitely believe it's either a god or somebody
god-related.
Maybe I'd better try talking to this person.
Here we go.
What the?
This person with much greater powers than me.
It's...
Missile?
You?
Hey!
Sizzle!
It's Missile!
Wait, does that mean Missile's dead?
Uh oh.
Oh my, it's...
Missile!
You look well for being dead.
Did you see?
Did you see what I did?
I did it!
I tried really hard and I did it!
I saved Miss Camilla!
What is done?
Are you telling me I was done in by a puppy dog?
Missile, what's going on?
How did you get the powers of the dead?
Yeah, I'm glad you asked!
After Miss Camilla went out and you left?
Run, run, run, Missile!
Yeah, Missile's back, Missile!
Misso, Misso, I worked like crazy to make my own path and I
did it!
Misso, oh!
Smart dog.
And then I followed Miss Camilla out into the big wide
world!
Oh my god, this is where it happened.
And then, here at this park, I found her alas!
Yes, you guessed it, I barked!
You bet I did, and I went running after her too!
And then I guess I died.
Missile.
And then I was unconscious for a little while.
Shaggy killed Missile.
then when i came to it was all over poor poor miss camilla
crushed underneath that big scary lump
oh what am i doing i'm so sorry little lady please forgive
me shaggy you must pay take me instead miss camilla
i had to rescue miss camilla it was up to me i cried out
from the depths of my heart and then oh I can't tell you how
surprised I was but I bet you understand right better than
probably anybody else could and then I remembered what you
did for me how you saved me so you went back right back to
four minutes before my wait that means Camilla and Missal
are able to communicate with each other Shaggy I hope...
I hope... I hope you never...
I hope the blue lady never smiles at you ever again.
You went back, right?
Right?
Back to four minutes before the little lady's death.
You bet I did!
Yeah, and that's why Camilla has a core.
Mm-hmm, mm-hmm, mm-hmm.
Yes, my knee are all over so gently, nab her, blah, blah,
blah, blah, blah, blah.
We've heard this before.
Then he says, come with me!
Awful.
I hate you, Shaggy.
Now's my chance.
I thought I saw the core.
Oh, now's my chance, I thought.
I saw the core.
I don't know.
It looks pretty far.
I stretched out my paw towards the core.
Oh, wow.
I felt that moment.
I'd love for you to be able to feel it, too.
Go ahead, Sissel.
Go ahead and try it for yourself.
Whoa!
I can't believe it.
How you... how could you connect over such a great distance?
Well, they don't call me Missle for nothing.
And so, then you manipulated that Mino thing and threw it
aside.
Right on top of my head.
Well, uh, no, actually.
Hmm?
I can't manipulate things like you can, Sissel.
You can't?
How did you...
I don't know what to...
I didn't know what to do.
Then I happened to see something out of the corner of my
eye.
And it had a core too!
A single leaf hanging from the tree.
So is Missile's ghost powers like...
Able to manipulate...
Like connect a thing.
So it kind of like swung.
Like his...
His power is this...
He like...
Swapping.
Oh, maybe swapping.
Oh, I don't know.
Let's see.
I thought he, like, had it swing over there.
I tried reaching out to the leaf.
What in the world?
I can't manipulate things.
But apparently...
Oh, he swapped them.
As long as the two things have the same shape that...
Oh.
That is so specific.
Swap things with the same shape.
Go ahead and try it.
First swap.
So now...
That's incredible!
Oh my gosh, this late into the game they're introducing a
new game mechanic.
No wonder this puzzle is so difficult.
So that's how you saved your mistress, is it?
And that's how I became caught up in this, is it?
I'm very sorry.
My powers were too meager.
Meager.
Because you see, I saw one more...
Oh!
I happen to notice one more core.
There was something with the exact same shape stuck in the
branches of a tree.
You're right.
It's the rugby ball.
Mino could be swapped again with that.
Then disaster wouldn't have to rain down on my head.
But what is that thing?
It's too big to be a leaf.
Whatever it is, I'd much prefer it on my head than Mino.
So why didn't you swap them, Mr. It's too far.
I couldn't.
I could stretch out my paw a little further than you can,
Sissel.
Aww.
But this was just too far for me.
I couldn't reach.
Da-dang.
No, it's not a beehive with the rugby ball.
Oh, sorry.
I must admit, it's a fascinating spectacle of a death.
If I do say so myself.
Oh well.
I kept retrying over and over, seeing if there was anything
I could do.
But there's something you can do now.
Hmm?
If we work together, you and me.
Cecil, you think so?
Wait, but then, but can we...
Can we save Missile?
I don't plan on letting anybody die in front of me tonight.
Do you think you could help me?
Of course!
Naturally!
to drop that mino thing in a different spot okay let's try
it let's go back again to four minutes before wait we have
to save miss i swear if she goes back if we go back to the
present she's alive and everything and oh wait though no
because she'll have already been kidnapped but if if
missal's just there lying in that in that pool in that poor
ditch.
I'll be so sad.
Let's get started.
Four minutes from now, you'll swap Mina with the leaf.
And then you'll have to swap Mina with something else.
Something with the same shape.
Oh, I believe that's a rugby ball.
Okay, a rugby ball, huh?
But with the rugby ball, where it is now, Missile can't
reach it.
So that means we have to move it closer somehow.
Looks like you and I will have to work together on that one,
Missile.
Whenever you want to use my swap trick, just press Z-R.
Okay, Z-R.
That way, you'll be able to control me.
And then if you press Z-R, control will come back to me.
Okay, let's try it.
Together we can stop Mino from hurting anybody.
Trick time.
Alright, Missile.
Your powers are the key this time.
Okay, I'm ready.
I can swap anything that has the same shape.
Just call on me if you want to...
If you find anything, you want to try.
Best thing to do is try and find a bunch of things and see
how it goes.
Use the R.
Alright, let's head back.
Open.
Uh...
Oh, wait.
Oh, there we go.
Oh, here he comes, here he comes.
Uh-oh.
Time is passing.
Oh, no, wait.
Um...
Wait, so can I swap the...
Let's see, Z-R.
Oh, and he can move further, too.
Yo!
That's so crazy.
Okay.
Maybe swap the basketball and that.
Oh, wait, but I'm in the baseball.
They're the same shape.
I think we need to...
Wait, how do I swap them?
Oh wait, blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah Swap What
does that do anything?
Because I'm still here That didn't really help me Hold
on Oh now it's too heavy Maybe because of the swap I made I
guess the little ball is about all the way I can handle Okay
Let's go ghost ZR Swap them back Let's swap the, uh...
Let's swap the, um...
Tire?
Oh my god.
Oh wait, uh, we'll stay here.
Z-R.
Oh wait, no.
Oh wait.
Hmm.
Okay, let's just see what else there.
Oh my god, he's just there.
There's also the love letter.
Look at this funny flattened
It's the same shape as that horrible Mino!
That's too far to swap from him.
Even this ball is starting to look horrible to me.
You have to find a way to get it closer.
Knock it down from the tree, I say.
There must be something we can do.
Time is passing.
And then he flies all his things around.
Oh man.
This is so tricky.
Hmm.
You're in the Seesaw, aren't you?
Uh, yes.
Okay, I can reach this.
So what if I do this?
Swap, and then, swap, and then, swap.
Okay, that should be it.
That should be it.
Now we, uh, oh, we need the Seesaw to move back.
Oh my gosh, please.
Move.
There we go.
And we go...
Oh, there we go.
No!
Ah!
Oh, oh, oh!
Okay.
Maybe...
Oh, maybe we have it so he doesn't...
What do you think of my lightning fast pace?
I wish he wouldn't knock it off.
I wish he would knock it off.
That's what I think.
We don't have time to prepare.
I think we're going to have to find a way to stop him from
running.
So...
Maybe we stop him from using the thing.
The seesaw, the swing, those things!
Precisely.
Except there are one more piece of equipment, to be exact.
Stop him with the equipment, eh?
Maybe I should rethink things here.
Well, hold on.
I'm still trying to...
Get over here.
Talk.
Why am I talking?
Oh no!
Wait!
Oh, I forgot.
Missile was in the baseball!
This is so confusing.
ball is still in the tree.
I know.
There isn't much more time.
I wonder if maybe the... Well, I don't think knocking the...
I don't think knocking the rugby ball with, like, a
basketball.
I don't think getting it on the ground is helpful.
I have to find a way somehow.
Okay.
You move there.
Oh, I'm still too short okay and
the swing we can't make it oh this one's really hard okay um
i feel like we need the tire oh the tire needs to go either
in here to make it too heavy for him to spin around or on
here to make it so he can he can't lift up hmm but it's also
timing because we need him to be on the swing so that we can
well do we need to connect to the swing maybe we don't oh
this one's tricky oh the balls are very important for the
puzzle yeah I can tell I've gathered that much
hmm hmm
Because, do I stop him from getting over here, like they
said?
Or do I get the rugby ball out of the tree?
Is the question.
Hmm.
I think you missed your chance at this point.
I agree.
No, I think so, too.
But, I think I'm still trying to cook a little bit.
I'm trying to...
I think it's probably easier to just do though, you know?
Because I can't even get over here!
So I think it has to be...
Oh, unless...
Okay, I'm possessing a ball.
Well, hmm.
I have to be able to possess a ball, I think, to be able
to...
When it gets launched in the air...
Right?
I think I have to possess something.
Maybe the basketball.
Okay, I'm just gonna restart.
I'm just gonna restart.
And we'll try swapping the balls a little bit.
Oh man.
Okay.
Let's go.
Open.
Sesame.
Okay.
if I may backseat for a moment I would advise simply solving
the puzzle oh thank you you're so right you are so right
where does a tire go oh we have to stop him from running but
I think he'll still try to spin so let's put the tire oh oh
no let's let's stay in the lid okay let's swap the tire okay
the baseball will swap these and then the tire I'm gonna
swap hello why can't I swap it oh oh I'm silly there we go
okay I don't know why it was getting it to me okay now two
okay i'm gonna try that and these two there we go okay let's
attempt this oh and now you get out of there we're just
gonna put you here i guess and then we're gonna put you in
the basketball oh shoot that's right it's too heavy ah oh um
thank you thank you and sebastian welcome to membership ah
that's right that's right that's right okay maybe I have to
swap and then be fast about it oh no no no no oh oh oh oh
okay move move Ah!
Okay.
No, no, no.
There we go, there we go.
Swap.
Okay.
CR.
There we go.
Okay, okay, okay, yeah.
Here you come already.
I swore to myself not to repeat my mistakes.
Mistakes?
When somebody is in trouble, you should lend them a hand.
Otherwise, you'll definitely regret it.
And now the recklessness of youth has taken over, giving me
lightning-fast speed.
I've been thinking If we could stop this man from running
Maybe he wouldn't get squished It won't be easy to stop me
once the recklessness of youth has taken over Stop him, eh?
Okay, so maybe now things are heavy enough Right?
Okay, he's not going so fast I think
Oh no, no, I thought I would be able to Oh Oh, I thought I'd
be able to move while I was launched, but I couldn't move.
Now I'm stuck.
Uh, okay.
Well, there was an attempt.
There was an attempt.
Time to throw in the trowel.
Yes.
Okay, let's retry.
Okay.
Hmm...
Maybe the tire needs to be on here then.
There.
Oh, no.
No!
Oh my goodness.
What?
Why?
Remember that your goal is to swap the statue with the ball,
not to stop him.
that I just need I think when the baseball gets launched
like it just sucks when I get launched I can't I can't ghost
trick so when I'm in the air I can't get up there you know
and we can't do anything with the with the balloon I'm
trying to think of any other shapes that are similar but
like the umbrella even when folded is not similar to
anything else.
And we can't reach that.
No, please, stop.
No.
Please, let me...
You know what, Sissel, get out of the way.
You go here.
Wait.
Yeah, you go here.
Oh, my God.
I'm going to become the Joker.
Please.
switch why isn't it working why isn't it working oh god stop
please oh my god
oh thank god holy moly
oh yeah we have to wait
No, no, no.
Put you here.
We're just gonna readjust a few things.
Maybe...
Maybe because it spins so fast, we put the ball in there.
The baseball might launch.
Maybe it will launch from the globe.
He'll spin really fast.
It will launch from the globe, and maybe it will hit the
rugby ball, from there who knows but with the tire here oh
wait i think i realized i need to well let's uh i think i
messed up okay hold on i did all that work but i think i
need to switch these guys again whoa what just happened um
order of operations wait um oh yeah oh
Can you spin the climbing frame fast when he's on it?
Oh, oh yeah, we can try, right?
Hold on.
The order of operation, wait.
My brain hurts.
Oh.
Because I want the ball.
Oh, okay, hold on.
Okay, let's switch these back again.
No, please.
Okay.
There we go.
Switch.
Even though it took me so long.
It's like to switch it before.
Cancel.
Go there.
Oh, oops.
There we go.
Oh.
My brain is hurting a little bit.
Okay.
Basketball here.
And now...
Switch.
Okay.
So let's try this.
And then...
Hope.
Wait, but how do I...
Oh, no.
It's too heavy to move.
I can't get over there.
Okay, we're gonna have to be the fastest in the West.
We're gonna have to be the fastest in the West.
Oh, wait.
Ghost.
Ball.
Move, move, move, move, move, move, move, move, move, move,
move, move.
Um.
Okay.
This one took me a while.
Ah, people.
Oh, my God.
He's already on it.
Oh, I still can't.
Okay, hold on.
Uh, shoot, shoot, shoot.
There we go, there we go, there we go, there we go, there we
go, there we go, there we go, there we go.
Okay.
Spin!
Spin it!
Wow, I didn't see this coming.
Okay.
Don't you know about the first thing about the globe, the
globe climber?
Huh?
little children treat it with respect with the respect it
deserves.
They know that unless you spin it gently, there's no
stopping it.
Yeah, it does look pretty dangerous.
Looks like I'm just destined to fly through the air like
this for a while.
Hmm.
This just might buy us some time.
Maybe he'll just keep spinning around like that for a whole
four minutes.
I'm sorry, but I don't think I would stand it for that long.
But anyway, at least we stopped him from running for a
while.
Let's see what we can do while we have our chance.
Okay.
Wait, there's two boots?
Look at that, there's two boots.
Okay, great.
Now, um...
Now we...
Uh...
You
go there.
Oh!
Oh my gosh, I can barely...
There we go.
Okay, we made it!
All right, wrestle this, just like before.
Now we can get up here, and we'll close the umbrella.
And now, that was so close.
If it hit the ball, it would have knocked it down.
Is that all this umbrella can be used for?
For knocking the rugby ball down?
about my powers.
Don't forget about my recklessness of youth.
Open it up.
Uh-oh.
Time is passing!
Did you see the seesaw?
I guess the tire's too heavy to get that much height.
I wouldn't have been surprised if it launched me into the
air.
The tire does have quite a bit of weight to it.
No matter how heavy it is, I can still swap it.
Wait, so So, maybe it shouldn't have been the tire.
Maybe we need him to jump into the air and flip the
umbrella.
Or something.
Ah!
Can he go into the rugby and drop manually?
No unfortunately.
Unfortunately we cannot.
I think I have to restart, though.
It took so long to get here, though.
Basketball did a perfect arc before.
Now did it.
The B-ball.
Okay.
So we need to move the...
We need to move...
The...
baseball wait no
but we still need the baseball in here so we're just
swapping the baseball and the basketball then is that it we
don't have to worry about the tire
boo thank you
I think I have to reset I know I think I've already missed
my chance I think I think if by the time he's there, it's
not completed.
It's not good.
I think, uh...
I think I'm...
I think I'm not good.
Right?
You have everything you need?
It's just execution.
I mean, I always had everything I needed.
Okay.
I'm gonna just retry.
retry with what we know now so okay and here we're the super
chat i don't know what it said though all right here we go
oh oh oh whoopsie whoopsie okay here we go la la la la la
move the seesaw into the seabow CISO go back down.
Here he comes.
Oh my gosh.
Already?
Okay.
Oh, wait.
Actually, you go here.
There.
Just a little bit of moving around a little bit.
Swap.
And now we wait for him to spin so we can get on...
so we can get on.
Oh, oh, oh, there we go.
Oh, wrong, wrong, wrong, wrong, wrong.
Oh, no, no, no, no.
Oh, my gosh, I'm pressing all the wrong buttons now.
Okay.
Now we spirit...
Spirits, spits, spits, spits, spits, spits, spits, spits,
spits, spits, spits, spits, spits, spits, spits, spits,
spits, spits, spits.
Ressel!
Now the question is, do I need to...
umbrella opener closed i'm not quite sure at this part i'm
gonna try with it open i don't know why oh whoops my bad
okay okay now i'm gonna wait
oh what did that just do i so did not see that coming oh i
never thought the umbrella would catch the boss Did you see
that?
The tree branch shook a little.
I think I saw it shake too.
If only it shook a little more.
It would knock that terrible rugby ball down from this
terrible tree.
Maybe it just needs a little more weight.
Sure we can do this.
We just have to put our heads together.
Okay, well I'm doing all the thinking right now, Missile, so
I could really appreciate it if you're just like...
Everything looks good so far.
We just need one more up.
The tire.
Wait, do I have to restart?
Oh!
Wait!
I get it!
I get
it!
I get it!
What do you think, Missal?
Okay.
I think you can do it.
Put the ball there.
I think I can do it!
In just a few seconds, you'll swap Mino with the leaf.
And then from there, you can swap Mino with one... Mino, one
more time!
The final moment is near, Missal.
Are you ready?
Okay, don't mess it up.
I'm going ghost!
Okay, I have to wait for it to start falling, don't I?
Yeah, I can't reach it.
I have to wait for it to start falling.
Okay, here we go.
Please don't make me have to do all this over again.
Please!
Ah!
Oh, there we go.
Okay.
Oh, okay, okay, okay.
Watch me, Sissel!
Here I go!
Oh, it did it for me.
That's so nice.
The finishing touches.
You can do it, Missile.
Swap Mino with that ball.
Swap.
Oh, okay.
I didn't have to time anything at all.
Nice.
Woo-hoo!
How's that?
My head has been spared.
Surely that was a try worthy of the gods.
Now Mino is right where he belongs.
Okay, we did it again, didn't we?
Didn't we?
Yeah, he's still in the same position.
Nobody has to die.
Missile.
Good job, Missile and Mint.
Nice, Missile.
Missile and Minto.
Except for one brave little Huh?
I'm talking about you, Missou.
Oh, me?
I guess you're right.
I'm still dead, aren't I?
So now let's go back and save your life.
Wait a minute.
What is it?
Now that I think about it.
I think I want to stay dead a little longer.
Oh, okay.
What?
When I was alive, I couldn't even help Miss Camilla when she
was in trouble.
I want to be able to protect Miss Camilla.
that any of these powers I have now.
I see.
Perfectly understandable.
Even I wish I had powers like that.
Hey, we just saved you.
Don't wish your life away already.
Of course, you're right.
You're such a good boy.
Okay, Miss Alvin, you're away.
By the way, Mr. Reckless Youth, there's a certain detective
who needs that music box you found.
Oh, he's such a good boy, no.
When we get back to the present time, could you give it to
her?
Certainly, you have my word.
Let's go back to the present.
Okay, oh my god, he's still there.
And so Camilla ended up in the hands of the kidnappers.
We weren't able to change that part.
Wait, but we don't want her to have the the music box oh no
wait we went yeah she's through the music box in there now
he's gonna wake up now Lynn is gonna get it that's right
missile is a diamond dog
Lynn listen to my story without saying anything I'm sorry I
wish there was something else I could have done no he did
the best you could I'm sure she's all right, after all.
After all, she has me!
Missal!
Missal?
Are you in there?
Miss Lynn!
Leave Miss Camilla to me!
I know I don't look much like much, look like, much right
now, but I'm sure I can help her!
Missal.
Oh.
Missile!
Oh no!
I'm gonna leave it up to Missile!
What are you talking about?
He's...
Oh my god.
It kind of looks like Missile is being left up to the wind.
Oh!
He's alive!
to give to you.
Da-da!
No, not.
Stop the park from being turned into a housing site.
Protect the park.
The rock of the gods.
Aren't you forgetting your promise?
Oh, pardon me, pardon me.
He's going on an adventure.
My apologies.
This is for you.
Oh.
Gonna need some more water soon.
You kept the music box safe, didn't you?
Thank you.
Not at all.
I was only doing with the Rock of the Gods.
Would have wanted...
Does he have a concussion or something?
What's wrong with him?
Mega Pocket.
What's the matter?
Cat got your tongue?
I think he thinks she's really pretty.
He's mesmerized by my beauty.
Hey, the cat's not allowed to get your tongue.
This is averted.
Evade, evade.
Excuse me, but are you?
No, it couldn't be.
Have we met before?
Aren't you?
That little girl from that time.
I'll never forget it.
It was 10 years ago in this park.
Shaggy!
Shaggy too.
Are you talking about...
Here in this park, the gods surely control fate.
Today, ten years from that day.
We meet once again.
If that isn't the power of the gods, then what else is it?
It could just be coincident.
He is lore.
I can't believe it.
But apparently, you know our lady detective here.
Could you tell us about it?
What happened ten years ago?
Yes, yes, of course.
I was actually about to do just that.
Rock of the gods.
What about this rock of the gods you keep mentioning?
Don't you know?
It's right there in front of us.
Me, no?
Oh, no, this place.
Oh!
Missile!
Aw!
Wait a minute.
You say gods, but do you mean dogs?
Of course not.
silly.
This is no time for ridiculous word games.
You are standing just above the Rock of the Gods.
Wait, you are standing just above the Rock of the Gods now.
Take a good look at that monument.
Monument?
Rock of the Gods.
Temsick Park.
The Rock of the... This took a turn that I did not expect at
all.
I mean, we've been dealing with...
We've been dealing with ghosts and all sorts of supernatural
stuff, but I did not, I don't know.
I don't, I did not expect something like this.
The rock is buried in the ground right there.
It's been there these 10 years.
Ever since that day, it flew down from the heavens and
showed us a miracle.
A miracle?
So this rock you've been talking about is a meteorite
precisely it's not a it's not a rock wait it's the opposite
it's not a boulder it's a rock it's a rock it dropped from
the sky on that day 10 years ago yes of course surely you
know all about it me
wait so did the mirror did the mirror the rock like strike
the guy so so the detective didn't actually shoot and kill
the person
that day i just happened to be passing through this park i
had no idea that day would change my destiny the sun was
going down and through the gloom i heard the scream of a
little girl
now just calm down and drop that weapon Stay back.
If you come any closer, I'll shoot her.
Oh my god.
That's not Cabanela, is it?
No.
No, no, because the guy died.
But look at that stance.
It looks very skinny and tall.
I peeked out fearfully from the bushes and saw some shadowy
figures.
I didn't see the face of the criminal clearing.
I knew I should do something to help, but I couldn't move.
The tension was so thick, it was painful.
Just when I couldn't stand it any longer.
That's when it happened.
The sky suddenly burned bluish-white.
Whoa!
I came crashing down on him.
When it crashed into the ground,
The meteorite gave off a shower of beautiful fragments.
This is how we get the ghost trick.
If you die where the meteorite has been, has little pieces,
that's why missiles are more powerful than ours.
That's why, because missile died right next to me, the
biggest chunk of the meteorite.
right and maybe the guy that died by the meteor is the
manipulator stellar stellar the meteorite gave up shower of
beautiful fragments oh my god it's just like oh my gosh you
know what it is it's just like the shikon jewel from enu
yasha and then i saw it one of those beautiful fragments
pierced into the criminal's back
he's the manipulator he's got the power of the rock the
judgment of the gods was brought down on the park that day
ten years ago the little girl that was you was saved by the
rock of the gods why I can't believe it the rock of the gods
was given the name Temsik and still today it lies sleeping
deep in the parks Earth.
So...
Where we died, there was a fragment.
Maybe not a fragment.
Maybe what that guy!
The scientist in the park!
Wasn't he studying?
Wasn't he studying the, um, the rocks?
He was studying the rocks in the, in his little lab.
Maybe that's why we have the powers.
Temsic.
I never knew about this Temsic.
I always thought Detective Jowd was the one who saved me.
You were very young then.
And you passed out from the shock of being taken hostage.
Of course you wouldn't remember.
But that's funny.
A huge incident like that should have caused quite a stir.
It's strange you've never heard of it, Lynn.
isn't it now I think about it I remember I didn't want to
think about what happened I avoided the news and it never
came back to this park again that's why I didn't know
anything about it the meteorite was named Tamsik after the
after the name of this park that it fell in and then the
rock of the gods was forgotten now an awful thing is
happening they're talking about turning the park into a
housing site I'll never forget the miracle I witnessed that
day park and i'm trying to appeal to the people protect the
park protect the rock of the gods that is my mission what's
a kismet i keep seeing people saying that what is that i see
the real mystery is how old is this guy i was thinking that
too oh it means fate oh i see i see i'm taking you with me
missile So 10 years ago, the little girl that was Lynn
wasn't aware of the meteorite.
I get that.
But Detective Jowd, on the other hand, there's no way he
didn't know about this Temsik thing.
And if he knew, then the man died, I took his life.
What was that confession of his all about?
I think Detective Jowd is just stupid.
I think Kismet means Jaeger.
Jowd hunters is real name
If kismet equals fate Temsik equals reversed fate I like
that Oh that's so big brain Because we're reversing their
fates That's so cool Yeah um Detective Jowd like what the
hell Why are you always like I killed this guy.
No, you didn't.
And also, oh yeah, I killed the wife.
No, you didn't!
What is the point of being the hero in this situation?
What was that confession of his all about?
The rocks of the gods that fell from the sky 10 years ago
changed the destinies of many people's lives.
Fakura, thank you.
Please don't build houses on the meteorite.
The town will become very bizarre.
It's true.
Like the ripples on a pond when a pebble is dropped in.
With every answer I get, I learn about a new mystery.
Will I be able to break the chain of mysteries before dawn?
The biggest thing...
The biggest thing is...
I still don't know who Cicil is.
I tried cooking before, and I was way off, I think, so
I'm...
I'm still... I'm still...
You know, I'm trying not to think too much about it.
Trying to just see how it plays out.
Anyway, now that we have the evidence we need, we decided to
meet up again at the minister's office.
Besides, there are a few things I wanted to ask Detective
Jowd.
We are way off to find out who we are.
We're here, oh my gosh.
We found the music box, Detective Jowd.
Good job, Lin.
I knew you would.
Once everything has been resolved, I had wanted you to give
this to him.
Him?
You mean Inspector Cabanella, right?
I don't suppose he'll ever forgive me.
Detective Jowd.
Now then, let's get this thing open.
There's a certain knack to doing it, you know.
Okay.
Oh, you just gotta pull it open.
Calls out a knack.
More like brute strength to me.
Oh, my...
It was the hammer space.
It's the hammer space.
Real.
You should...
You should find scorch marks on the grip.
Scorch marks.
When Camilla built her contraption, she used a special kind
of string.
Yeah, don't look down the barrel.
What's wrong with you?
It's a kind of magician's use.
It burns up in an instant and disappears.
Why would little Camilla use something like that?
I don't know.
Maybe because she's a detective's daughter.
Not leaving any evidence behind and all that.
In the case report, there was mentions of some scorch marks.
On what?
Oh, on the walls.
I'm supposed...
I'm guessing.
When it happened, Camilla was watching from her hiding
space.
Revolver jowled.
She saw the flame run to the gun, something she naturally
didn't include in her design.
I took the gun out of the frame and replaced it with a
picture.
If you remove the picture, you should find scorch marks
behind it on the frame, too.
And those marks should match up with the ones on the gun.
In other words, it proves the control.
Attraction existed there in that room that day.
Hmm.
And it didn't work the way your little girl intended, is
that right?
Exactly.
Some cowardly culprit modified the design.
But that angle was never brought up in court.
And so as justice minister, I must call off the execution at
this point.
Yippee!
I knew I was right.
Detective Jowd.
Now we can finally prove that.
Thank goodness.
Thank you, Lynn.
In those eyes of yours, I see the eyes of that little girl
from ten years ago.
Cicel.
If you hadn't come to my cell tonight, I would be gone by
now without ever having known any of this.
This is what I deserve.
I told myself these past five years.
Well, things are different now.
Thanks to you, my eyes have finally been opened.
Tonight.
I've come into contact with a lot of people's lives and got
involved in their fates.
Yeah, don't I deserve to know who I am now?
The only reason I was doing that was to regain my own lost
memory.
But things are different now.
We're connected to each other somehow.
I just know it.
That's why I need to ask you a few more questions.
to find the truth about us.
Yeah, we gotta investigate the real mystery now.
Fair enough.
Fire away.
Sorry.
I'm, like, so invested in this now.
Let's check out the manipulator.
Hold on, I'm taking a sippy.
My throat is getting so dry.
Okay.
Yeah, I think I will stop after this just because my throat
is, like, I've been talking so much today.
Sissel told me all about it, Detective Jowd.
the manipulator yes and it looks like this manipulator
really did a number on the minister too please don't pick on
the minister if he dies again i'm the one who has to save
him
sisal do you think do you think that's what happened to me
too what are you talking about lynn yeah i think so don't
tell me you were manipulated too
there was always a part of me that just couldn't believe
believe it.
That image of the one who shot me.
But now I see the possibility of a new explanation.
But who is it?
And why did they do it?
Hmm.
Camilla's contraption.
That contraption was a birthday surprise for Camilla's
mother, wasn't it?
That's right.
something's been bothering me about it I feel like I know
that device from somewhere oh she finally realized no
surprise there you lost your life once once tonight because
of that machine right I knew it see detective Jowd oh I'm
afraid I don't see detective Jowd is a great detective if he
walks up to a crime scene and says he did it technically he
solved it and he gets the credit that's He has a spotless
record.
It was me.
Flashback.
I told Detective Jowd about it.
Told him about seeing the exact same contraption tonight in
a completely different place.
That's very strange indeed.
I was like thinking for a second.
I was like, why would she think to know this?
Or rather...
Why did they do it?
They were doing a little silly.
Rather, I was thinking why does the... why did the scientist
guy know about it?
I'm...
You know...
Part of me is just like is he a bad guy and told her how to
make it and then knew how to manipulate it?
Um...
So that it would be...
It would be...
lethal?
Hmm.
Yeah, or the scientist was investigating.
Obviously, like, that's, you know, the other half.
But...
Hmm.
That's very strange indeed.
A junkyard on the edge of town.
I've never even heard of the place.
And what's more, I've never told a single soul about that
contraption.
You haven't?
Hmm, that old pigeon guy.
Who in the world is he?
Yeah!
Tomsek.
Detective Jowd, you must have heard this name before.
Temsik.
The meteorite that fell in the park ten years ago.
You were there.
So you found out about that, did you?
I heard that meteorite saved little Lynn's life.
And then you took the credit!
That's right.
I couldn't do anything to help Lynn that day.
But in that case, I don't get it.
If it's true, doesn't it mean you didn't steal somebody's
life away?
What are you talking about?
Detective Jowd, you told me that 10 years ago.
The person who killed the perpetrator in the park was you.
What?
It was the meteorite!
Yeah, you weirdo.
I wasn't lying.
Also, this is totally unrelated, but it's been bothering me
for so long.
Every time I see this portrait of Detective Jowd standing
right here with the text blocking him, his shirt reminds me
of Osumatsu-san.
He reminds me of...
Not Karamatsu.
With the pink one.
It makes me think of it every time.
And it distracts me so much.
What's the pink one's name?
Ah.
Gosh, I can't remember.
To do Mats!
I think of him every time.
He has a little design.
On Toti!
It's so funny.
If anybody's wondering, I was a Ju Shimatsu girl.
I wasn't lying.
I stole that man's life away.
No question about it.
It was entirely my fault.
I was just about to shoot him.
Ichimatsu was the sad guy, wasn't he?
I would have shot him in the next instant if the meteorite
hadn't come.
At that point, I was already a murderer.
That's not how that works.
That's not true.
You were trying to save me.
Lynn, I'm sorry, but I don't think that's really it.
Huh?
The truth about 10 years ago...
Uh-oh.
On that day, 10 years ago, a different...
happened in another place.
Another place?
Yes, in the police headquarters interrogation room.
This guy just can't stop lying.
The worst sort of incident.
A suspect who was being questioned escaped.
Wow, I didn't know about that.
I happened to be there in the detective division, so I
joined the chase.
Fortunately, or I guess unfortunately.
I was able to track him down alone in the park.
Hold it right there.
I fired a warning shot.
I wanted to catch him bad.
That warning shot made him panic.
At the time, I was a young and green detective, brandishing
my sense of justice like a sword.
I made him panic and got you involved, Lin.
It was all my fault.
Detective Jowd.
All I could see was my target.
see you.
I'm so sorry, So he didn't really have her interest in best,
her safety in mind is what he's trying to say.
My sword is a tool of justice.
Well, you know what they say about that sword.
So the man who grabbed me died that day.
These last ten years.
I've never forgotten his face.
And then a few years after that, when my wife Alma died in
such a mysterious way.
I thought it was fate.
My punishment was for what I'd done.
I mean, that would make sense why the manipulator went after
Zhao's wife.
He's just like...
Revenge, baby.
Revenge!
Cha-cha.
I've painted pictures in my cell.
Nothing but portraits of people's faces.
Sa- 13.
Welcome to membership.
Thank you.
All the faces of the many people I met in my life and didn't
want to forget.
Revengeance.
And tonight, it was our face.
It was Cicel.
I finished my last portrait.
The final face I wanted to remember.
The final face.
The face of the man in the park that day.
Huh?
Wait, just one minute!
That can't be!
I saw that painting!
I saw the face you painted tonight!
What?
It was my face!
Are you telling me I was the man in the park that time?
right that face of yours is the face I saw 10 years ago the
face of the man whose life I stole of the man who was
pronounced dead at the scene but but hold on detective Jowd
I can't be true I just met Cicel for the first time tonight
did Someone reverse our fate?
Somehow.
Maybe.
Did he think we were dead, but then someone revert- Huh?
And he died right in front of me!
By the way, the name that I know the man in the park that
day by isn't Cicil.
What?
From the first minute I laid eyes on you tonight, I've been
wondering.
Who in the world is this guy?
Mr.
Minister.
Inspector Cabanela, where are you?
Oh, he's at the Pigeon Man.
Just be quiet and listen.
This is our demand!
You double-crosser, you!
I knew it!
Demand?
Our demand hasn't changed.
The execution must be enough.
Unless he's being manipulated.
Once we've confirmed it's been carried out, we'll release
the hostage.
about inspector Cabanela and you know it wasn't my daughter
who was abducted does it really matter who the hostage is a
laugh is a laugh even if it's the daughter of a death row
prisoner once the criminal gets the punishment he deserves
the hostage will go free carry out the execution immediately
and wait for our call
what is it mr.
minister you look paler than ever I think he's What in the
world?
What is going on?
Inspector Cabanela!
Oh my god, what is going on?
And for real, the rock of the gods that fell from the sky 10
years ago twisted the fate of many people and started a
chain of tragic events.
And even now, the chain continues to grow even longer.
Inspector Cabanela's call proved that to us.
What the hell?
The greatest mystery of all has risen to the surface.
Who is this me I've been chasing all night?
The music is so awesome.
Who am I?
I'm Minto!
I'm even further from knowing than when I started.
Who am I?
Wow, it's 2.55 a.m.
Oh my goodness.
The link's past.
Save the data.
Stop the playing.
Wow.
I think, yeah, I think we'll finish it tomorrow.
We stopped.
We have three more.
16, 17, and 18.
Oh, no, wait.
We left on 14, right?
Hold on.
15, 16, 17, 18, wait.
15, 16, 17, 18.
Okay, so four, one, two, three, four.
Four more.
And that'll be part five, which I think is a good, like,
uh...
You're upstream.
A good...
Uh, number.
You wouldn't have been able to stop if you got any further.
I don't think so either.
We haven't seen the blue guy and his henchmen from the
beginning in a long time.
Looking forward to seeing how this ends.
Me too!
It's been, yeah.
I've been thinking about them.
Arranged version.
Because there's uh, originals, right?
Is this the original version?
And then...
Oh.
Oh, it is quite...
different actually you're going to like the next level i am
a ho is the best one in the game i'm excited i'm excited oh
okay so tomorrow same time same place we'll finish it up um
we'll get through the next four chapters we made a really
good great progress though we went through one two we went
through four chapters today so good job everybody good job
job interview on friday i need luck mint or i suppose a
manipulator would help no no no if you got me in there mia
i'd be like i'd be like oh oh the
stream did uh obius something something obius stop for a
second YouTube died.
No, it was OBS.
Okay.
That means...
That means it's time for me to...
quit it.
That means it's time for me to quit, I believe.
Well, guys...
Um, hold on.
I'm trying to bring up my chat again because YouTube was
being kind of silly.
It always gets delayed after a certain amount of time.
Uh-oh.
Wait, YouTube is dead for me.
Oh boy.
Oh boy!
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
YouTube.
Live.
Here we go, okay.
Okay, here we go.
Alright.
See you tomorrow, Minto!
Ototu!
Thank you!
Alaric!
Thank you for the stream.
Thank you guys so much for joining me again today.
Tomorrow we'll wrap up the and yeah I'm gonna go I'm
actually I was gonna talk for a bit but I think I'm gonna go
because my throat is quite sore I'm gonna go take some of my
wait I think I'm out of my medicine I forgot to order more
I'll get some more at least gonna get some water so I can
yeah but um saw something cool today on Twitter um almost
made pretty derby collab with top top wait what there's a
top gun collab with umabusebe
how did i miss this this is from like last week oh my god
how did i miss this oh my god
that's so awesome oh my god oh my god oh my god mint brain
rot is activated you were gone for a bit i guess so oh my
god oh my god yo that's so crazy no way oh my gosh top gun
maverick my beloved
wait it's two years and a week ago Oh my god, you're right.
It says 2022.
Why did nobody ever tell me?
This page is probably going to wonder why I retweeted their
thing.
I guess it would make sense when the movie came out, right?
Because it wouldn't make sense.
It wouldn't make sense if it was now.
I was like...
It wouldn't make sense if it's like, I was like, why is it,
why is Top Gun doing a thing now?
Right?
Movie's a little old now.
It's still new in my heart.
I think that's why I didn't even question it.
I was like, I just watched it yesterday.
Uh, alrighty.
Anyway, thank you guys again.
I'm gonna go, I'm gonna go sleep.
Or, yeah, oh, I've got some stuff I need to do and then I'll
sleep.
room for the finale and we will finish off ghost trick
tomorrow and um uh what's tomorrow wednesday i will try and
have a schedule out for this week it probably i mean it's
already late i'm really sorry i'm so late sorry it's okay
not it's okay um devs please rerun
um yeah sorry for the late schedule it's just my brain was
um but i do have a collab this this week I believe I believe
I have a collab um going on later on Thursday so uh you can
look forward to that maybe if you can't make a schedule this
week it's totally okay but I still need to I want to um
because I still have Friday uh Saturday I have the truck
event so I won't be streaming And then Sunday as well.
I'll need to make for Sunday.
Boom.
With Mouse and Henya, it leaked?
Who said it?
Who leaked?
Which one of them?
Which one of them leaked it?
Mouse said it.
Okay.
But yeah, Mouse and Henya will be showing me around the
vshoujo minecraft server so um uh i was i haven't gone into
it yet i've been very nervous to go in because i'm scared of
all the mods that they have and stuff um but yeah oh thank
you for the raid i can't read it savvy thank you savvy um
okay asaminto everybody have a good night and i'll sorry for
the raiders um
Uh...
I uh...
I'm ending.
I'm so sleepy.
Okay, bye bye!
Who gifted?
Taki!
Thanks for the gifted.
bye bye
bye oh my
god that's what wb32 thank you for the best thank you
captain thank you thank you thank you thank you thank you oh
my gosh thank you so much